Sorry, we were waiting on Mint.
She had to put on a space suit.
Oh yeah, it was all me.
Yeah, it was all Mint.
I have my space suit on!
Yeah, while we were waiting, uh, Nimue sent us a very, uh...
Hey, it was from the theme page.
Why on the theme page?
Oh, I see what's happening in that picture.
I just was focused on...
I didn't even see it.
Oh...
Like, I was like, I didn't... Oh...
I see, I see.
It's that kind of game, huh?
Yeah, it's that kind of game.
It's gonna help a brother out, you know?
We'll see if that happens to any of us.
Yeah.
What a way to go, you know?
What a way to die.
This is some people's real fantasy, though.
Yay!
Honestly, it is.
Wait, where did you find this?
On the Steam page?
Yeah, it's on... No, it's on the...
It's on the official Steam page for the game.
Oh yeah, but...
You guys are wondering...
What?
I'll show.
Yeah, I'll show.
I'll show too.
I'll put it on the screen for the...
This is for the class.
Here you go, everybody.
Why don't you share the cluster to the class?
Nimi?
Why don't you...
Oh gosh, I'm sharing it.
I... I take no responsibility for this image.
This was...
This was posted for everyone to see on the Steam page.
It was out in the public.
This is why Doki chose this game.
Yeah, yeah.
I saw this...
I saw that...
That specific image.
I was like, damn.
The perfect game.
What?
I don't know why...
I wonder why he died.
Yeah!
Weak, that's all I'll say.
Weak!
Hello everybody!
Welcome to...
The green-yellow collab.
Yay!
Let's go green!
Yeah, let's go green!
Let's go yellow!
We all have a little bit of green on us.
Yeah, and we all have a little bit of yellow on us, too.
Wait, that's true.
Yeah.
We're really actually cohesive.
Oh, yeah, we are.
The green-yellow-woman collab.
The lobby close.
Wait, no, we're all still here.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, come back to us.
Come back, come back to space.
She landed back on Earth.
She had... I got ejected.
I got voted out.
Yeah, you got voted out.
Oh, no.
Gotta do your task.
Yeah, someone was not doing their task.
Why didn't you fix the lights when it was off, Doobie?
Sorry.
I'm busy looking at an image, really.
She passed one.
She got ejected.
Yeah.
I think that makes Nimi the most size.
Oh, that's true.
Don't vote me out.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I've never played the game before.
None of us have played the game before.
Excuses, excuses.
Yeah, none of us have played the game before.
What are you talking about?
Yeah, do we know what kind of game this is?
It's basically... Actually, no.
I mean, it's like one of those proximity chats for co-op games, right?
Yeah, it's a proximity chat for co-op games, right?
Yeah, it's a proximity chat.
You know what's funny?
I suggested the game, too.
I was like, um...
No.
I just know we're exploring the moon.
It's like...
We're trying... Oh, wait, no.
We're trying to find the moon.
And return alive.
So it's like a friend's loss.
Trying to find the moon?
Yeah.
We lost the moon?
Oh, yeah.
It did say something like that.
You have to find the moon.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't...
Oh.
How could... Oh, my gosh.
Gru did it.
He fucking did it.
He stole the moon and we're trying to find it back.
We're just little minions.
My scheme is offline.
I gotta fix it.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Take your time.
But it's not Tuesday.
Oh.
Is it Tuesday?
I've already lost.
No, it's not.
Okay.
It's definitely Friday.
Happy Friday.
Yay.
Happy Friday, everybody.
Happy Friday, everyone.
Happy Friday.
Also, Soundgat, my...
For people who are, like, wondering about the sound, we're gonna be using the in-game VC.
But, like, the lobby VC is so quiet.
Yeah, we gotta, like, get in-game and kind of fix it.
Yeah, yeah.
But we sound like we're in space, though.
That's the best part.
We sound like we're actually in our little spacesuits.
Sounds like Xbox mic.
It really is.
I'm gonna get on there.
I'm gonna be, like, a ten-year-old.
I'm gonna cuss you out.
No, be like, John Madden.
John.
You say, you freaking...
You freaking dummy.
All right.
You're gonna get banned for that kind of language.
Oh, that's true.
I will.
I'll report you.
David's looking right now.
Oh, no.
John Madden.
It's like 15 plus years old.
And it's still funny.
It's still got it.
Every, like, couple of months, I think about it.
Oh, no.
All right.
Uh, do...
Oh, wait.
Is it Steam still down for you, Doobie?
Um, it was up.
Like, I closed it and then I relaunched it and then I connected.
But now I'm disconnected again.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's not good.
Hold on.
Oh, it was working.
Sorry.
It's okay.
It's all right.
We're bonding.
We're having a bonding session before we betray each other in space.
There's no rules in space, Batman.
Is PvP enabled?
Is PvP a thing?
I know.
I was like, is it even a thing?
I don't know.
I mean, can we fight the monsters or no?
I mean, I hope so.
We can with our mouth.
I mean, with words.
We're in worrying.
We're the words.
That's what she means.
We'll just...
We'll say very mean words to them and they'll go away.
Sticks and stones.
Yeah, yeah.
Isn't it probably like the opposite?
Like, it'll sense when you talk or something and then we'll fight.
Oh, yeah.
Probably.
They'll fight us.
Apparently, this game is made by one person.
We can attribute everything to them.
Yeah, that's true.
She made it.
I'm in.
Oh my god.
All right, I'll start the lobby.
Okay.
Wait, should we mute everybody then?
Oh, I forgot.
She didn't choose her color.
All right, she's white now.
Okay.
I'm white.
Yay!
Okay, I'm gonna...
Wait, we turn everybody to zero.
Yeah, we turn everyone to zero in this grid.
All right.
Okay, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
All right.
Hello?
All right, I'm gonna turn...
I'm gonna fix the audio.
Hello?
I'm gonna turn my mic up.
It's pretty quiet.
Okay, my mic up is up.
Is it up for you guys?
A little bit.
A little better.
All right, it's at 250.
250.
Okay, I'll put mine at 250.
Yeah.
That's the max.
Hello?
Are you too loud?
No, louder.
250.
Put it at 250.
I said 250.
I put it at 250.
Oh my god.
250.
It was...
It did improve for the others, but...
Yours is still a little quiet, Doobie.
Wait, Nimmi, can you try talking?
Hello?
Komakuwa.
All right, I'm gonna turn...
The other stuff up.
It's gonna be so quiet.
Maybe we turn the game, like, volume up.
Yeah, I'm gonna do that.
I'm doing that right now.
I'm turning the game.
Yeah.
Everything's gonna be really loud.
I turned the game...
Oh wait, I'm gonna turn the game...
Other game stuff lower.
How do you do that, though?
Yeah, is there other games though?
I think...
Oh my god!
Oh, Toby, you did it!
Did you fix it?
But you fixed it!
You fixed it!
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, you're like...
I think...
Your microphone...
Should I turn it down?
No, it's...
It's...
It's like peaking, so like, it's like...
I hear like 5th, we...
Wait, it doesn't peak for us, but your setup is peaking and like, we can only hear like...
Okay, I think it's the master volume.
You turn down the master volume, and that's the game.
The game is master.
It's not...
No, it does.
Oh, does it?
Oh, it does!
Never mind, it does.
I just turned...
Yeah, I turned it back up.
I just turned it back up.
Well, doobie, how did you fix it on your end?
What did you do?
Oh, I just turned it back up.
Is it still on the back?
It's still so loud.
Oh.
Hold on.
Luckily...
Luckily, we're all streaming our POVs.
Yeah, let me...
Okay, okay.
Someone will combine it, I guess.
Someone will sync up all our audios together.
Quite the worst campaign.
The ultimate compilation.
Like, I don't understand.
Why is there no individual toggles?
It's just...
Okay.
It really feels like we're in space, guys.
I don't think we're in space, though.
Wait, this is a parking lot.
Why are we in the parking lot?
I can't crouch.
Okay, it's...
Oh, yeah.
See, it's crouch.
Wait, how do we get...
Oh my god.
Wait, how are you dancing?
Yeah, how do you dance?
Hold G.
G?
Oh, I see.
What's this?
Ho!
Whoa!
Whoa, Doobie!
She's dooping out!
Wait, Doobie!
Wait, it's not for Doobie!
Wait, what's happening, Doobie?
Hello!
You're just saying hi.
Wait, I go over there.
We're just do...
Wow, guys, I didn't know space was just a parking lot.
I...
Oh, you have a creepy van, too.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, what are we trying to do?
What?
You saw the image.
I don't know what we're trying to do.
I can't.
All right, where do we go?
So we have equipment.
Can we go inside?
We're supposed to turn on electricity on the right floor.
Oh, right here.
Oh my god, it's Phasmo.
Wait, let me turn down my sensitivity.
Okay.
Oh, it's echo in here.
There.
Oh.
The words that can be interacted with are highlighted with a faint light.
That's good to know.
Oh, there's a special book.
What's this?
I don't know how to read.
Someone else read the special book number one.
What does it say?
What does it say, Mint?
Hello?
Mint?
Mint, are you okay?
Doobie?
You stop talking.
I think I'm possessed.
Mint, Doobie, you're not talking.
Wait, does it limit us when we're...
We entered the building and we're like in our own little like inner dimension.
The pocket dimension where we can only hear one of the...
Oh no, the yellow and green.
The yellow and greens.
The swap.
It's like, you know, it's like wife swap.
We swapped the greens.
Okay.
It's okay.
We can do this.
Yeah.
We can do this together.
We just...
Whoa!
What?
There's a kitten.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this?
Is it alive?
I don't know.
It's a giant ass cat.
I'm very lucky.
I know.
Hello little guy.
Okay, we gotta find the power.
All right.
I hope Mint and Doobie can work together.
And then Nimi and I, we can do this.
It's gonna figure out where.
Oh, we gotta figure out.
What was that?
Oh!
Oh wait!
Oh, wait.
I can hear!
I can hear you.
It jump scared me and it be able to hear you guys.
I can...
I can hear you.
Wait?
You hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you.
I can hear...
I got jumped...
It jump scared my game.
Is it hearing you guys?
Wait.
Apparently we just clicked V on accident.
Ah!
I saw you muted yourself.
Yeah.
You just muted me.
Why didn't you guys press me?
Why?
Because we were probably trying to find a cool emo or something.
Yeah, we were probably trying to press G.
Whoa.
Okay, anyway, there was an alien outside that window.
Oh, we heard it.
Yeah, yeah.
It was really loud.
I'm scared.
I got a TV.
Oh, nice!
What's on the TV?
Um, it says, uh, no signal.
Oh, okay, we got a person.
Wait, this looks like electricity.
Oh, wait, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, turn that on.
Nice.
We did the first task.
Wait, the cat.
The cat?
Oh, the cat?
Oh, no.
The cat's still sleeping.
Guys, I don't think there's a space.
I don't think...
What's the transmitter doing?
Why is the moon in the...
Like...
Like, I... Oh, we have to find the moon, right?
Oh, yeah, we have to find the moon, yeah.
Wait, maybe we're gonna build a rocket.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Well, we're on the first floor, so we gotta go downstairs.
It's locked.
Close on the other side.
Oh, down here?
Hello.
Is the sensitivity weird for anybody else?
It's a dead end.
Oh, um, just do the controls.
It's on controls.
Yeah, I turned mine down.
Is it?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna turn mine down.
Fucking, my chat's like, um, it's actually, Earth is also in space, so...
Oh, true.
True.
That's true.
Brain chat.
We're just LARPing.
Close on the other side.
Oh, there's more over here.
We kind of are, like, we put on our spaces already.
Yeah, we're like these kids that are, like, um...
The save game.
Oh, we're here, we're here.
Oh, the game has been saved.
Oh, this has to be the basement.
Doesn't have to be.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, that's us!
It's us.
Oh, we can change the color.
Doobie, you don't have to be white anymore.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I'll be blue.
Blue!
That's a different blue than mince blue, right?
Yeah, yeah, it is, it is.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's cute.
What's this?
Oh, we have... Oh, get previously researched items.
Current distance.
Oh, wait.
Is this the book that we...
Current objective is displayed in the corner.
Yeah, I don't know.
Close on the other side.
How do we get out...
Out of here?
Ooh.
Okay, the last time I was alone, something happened.
I like how...
Like, it's like, we're in like a little suburban area.
Yeah, I'll see...
Yeah.
We're gonna swear to school or something, right?
Yeah, we're...
Scary out there, though?
Do you see that?
What?
See what?
By that building over there?
What?
I don't see anything.
Are you sure any...
Did you take your meds, Nimi?
Nimi?
Yeah.
I swear I see it.
I'm by the building.
Nimi, that's just a regular kid.
That's just...
There's a kid?
That's...
No, yeah.
You guys not see that kid over there?
That's not a kid.
Yeah, there's a regular...
There's a kid out there.
Do you not see it?
Is this guy in the corner?
Yeah, there's a kid.
It's like 12 feet tall.
What?
He took his vitamins.
He took his vitamins and grew 12 feet tall.
That's like Popeye.
When your nurse starts seeing things, I start worrying.
Isn't that...
No, we didn't go forward.
It feels like a safe room, no?
But what's...
What's over there, though?
Oh, it's a safe terminal.
Okay, but where is, like, the fucking basement?
Was it where we were before?
Weren't there stairs?
Not working.
Oh!
So that's...
The one area we didn't go.
I think maybe there...
Oh, there's a lot of stuff in here.
A monitor.
A shelf for...
Oh, a shelf for special books!
Oh, the special book!
I'll go get it.
Alright.
We put them on in here.
Oh, there's a transmission status here.
So we put our special stuff here.
Okay.
Perma upgrades?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're figuring it out.
How cozy.
Yeah.
Where did they go?
They have the special book and everything.
I got the special book.
Hello, little guy.
Aw, she's, like, purring.
Oh, wait!
The basement's here!
Guys!
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
There were stairs.
There were stairs the entire time.
The whole time.
Well, it's good to explore.
Yeah, yeah, that's true.
We found, like, our little safe room, too.
Yeah.
I brought those.
Oh, guys!
We found the basement!
Does it work?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I found the basement.
There were stairs that we forgot.
Oh, wait.
I think you put the...
Wait, it says installation monitor.
Do we have?
We put the monitor here?
A TV's a monitor.
A monitor.
Guys, I don't think it's the TV.
I don't think it's the TV.
Maybe the TV's too old.
Yeah, it's too old.
It's not...
It's like a CRT.
We don't live in those ages anymore.
Alright, we found the...
Mint, get the fuck up.
We have...
We gotta find the moon!
We gotta...
Yeah, we gotta explore the basement.
We gotta find the moon, guys!
It's over here.
It's down here.
The moon!
Is there any explanation for the giant cat?
It's a moon cat.
I like him, though.
It's a spit...
Yeah.
He's purring.
Maybe he's like a guard...
It's like a guard dog, but a cat.
Maybe space is okay.
Yeah.
You know, space has giant cats.
Alright, ladies first.
Oh, this is a very suspicious entrance.
How do we go upstairs?
What's up here?
Um, it says explore the basement.
They're gonna punish you.
No!
Closed on the other side.
I think we have to do the basement before we can unlock the other floors.
Probably, yeah.
Can we fall?
Oh, we can't jump.
To a flip.
To a flip!
Alright, let's go downstairs.
Alright.
Doobie, you first.
You're a very brave woman.
What?
I've seen you break dance.
You can take them.
Oh my god, you're so brave, Doobie.
You're just...
You're so brave!
You're so strong and brave!
You don't care about me.
You don't care.
Yes, I do.
Of course I care.
I...
I thought you were gonna be my knight in China Gormor.
When dying, if there are other surviving players...
Uh...
Hi.
Oh, so this will be...
Oh, all players must be into...
Oh, wow, it's really upset.
Uh...
We go to...
Basement 2.
There's a basement too?
That's just another basement.
Wait, do you guys have flashlights?
Yeah.
Oh, how do you turn it on?
Wait.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, where'd it go?
Wait, I think that's that guy.
I think that's the guy.
I think it's...
I think...
I think it's that guy.
There's a kid from outside.
This is the 12 feet guy.
The nevi saw.
Oh my gosh, she did see a guy.
Oh gosh.
We're like colliding so bad.
Oh.
We need a lever.
We need to find a lever.
Alright.
I can't see anything.
Someone with a flashlight go first.
You don't have a flashlight?
No.
I swear you're holding one.
It's a transmitter.
Whatever that is.
Oh, I think because you're holding a transmitter.
Maybe.
I think someone's dead.
Wait, someone's dead?
Who's dead?
Oh my god.
That was you!
Wait, yeah.
It's Doopie1.
Doopie1.
DoopieAlpha.
It's like that...
The Mickey...
What was it?
The one with Robert Pattinson?
Oh, I like that one.
Mickey17.
Yeah, Mickey17.
That was...
That was Doopie...
Doopie16.
Wait, where did Doopie17 go?
Doopie17, why did you go in here?
Doopie, Doopie.
Wait!
Doopie17, why did I get down there?
There's a monster down here.
Wait!
Oh my god, Did everybody get down, Doopie!
I got down.
It's aaurus!
It's a 210!
Doopie!
I don't think we can go back up.
I think... I guess we're about to meet Doobie 18.
Doobie 17 is gone.
I think it opened up this thing right here.
Oh, apparently Doobie... Oh my god.
No!
Okay, the timing of that was crazy.
Okay, do we have to restart?
Yeah, well let's restart the lobby then.
Yeah, we're pretty early on because we didn't know what to do.
I kinda wanna see what happens.
Alright, you guys wanna die to the monster together?
Yeah.
Alright, we'll go.
Hopefully it's not too loud.
Sorry guys.
Prepare your ears.
Wait, where was he?
Over here.
Was he over here?
Oh, there he is!
Alright, who wants to die first?
I'll go.
Alright, we'll watch.
She's gonna get the...
I don't know.
That was crazy.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, I'll go.
I'll make a new lobby.
I'll make a new...
We all ended up back here, y'all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god, that was crazy.
I got dunked on.
Oh my god.
Okay, I made a new lobby.
Welcome back, everyone.
Hello.
Welcome.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh...
Alright, let me...
Okay, we made a new lobby.
Hi.
Holy shit.
I did not expect that death.
I...
It's so loud now.
Oh my god.
When did we like give you when you were like, oh god.
Holy shit.
That was fucking crazy.
Alright, I got you.
Alright, I said I...
I...
Um...
Messaged Doobie that we made a new lobby.
Yay.
So we'll just wait.
I'm trying to send her an invite to me.
Oh yeah, I am.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, cause I wasn't able to send an invite.
Alright, I'm gonna go get water real quick.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm back.
No, don't be sorry.
No problem.
Oh my god.
We saw you died, whore.
We turned the corner.
We go look for you.
We found the monster.
I did, that's what happened.
That's why.
Disconnected me.
Alright, I'm back.
Oh my god.
I'm back.
Doobie.
Oh, we're back.
You crash at like the perfect time.
Really?
We're like, we're like, oh man.
Yeah, I hope we don't have to clone Doobie17 and then you disappeared.
Alright, now we can speedrun it.
We know we know.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, we know, we know.
Alright, I'll start the lobby.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, hello everyone.
We're here.
Yeah, we're here, right here.
We're back here.
Yeah, yeah, okay, we know what the alien does.
We know.
What do you mean?
Um, okay.
Okay, actually, no, we can watch Doobie also encounter him.
What?
Yeah, Doobie, we all, it's like initiation.
We all did it.
We all...
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Alright, he's friendly, right?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, very friendly.
We all got a hug from him, right, guys?
This isn't related to the picture you guys showed me earlier, right?
Oh, okay, there he is.
Oh.
Alright, Doobie.
He really just does that, doesn't he?
Alright, Doobie 18.
Woohoo!
Time to get to work.
Is this right?
Yeah, I think so.
Wasn't he around here?
Yeah, he was right here.
And then the left side.
We'll watch.
He's right here.
Okay, ready, Doobie?
Oh, I see him!
Yeah.
Are we gonna die him?
No, no.
No, we all gave him a little hug.
How did we get him not to see us, though?
I think we could go left.
Yeah, I think we have to go around him.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, this is just the beginning.
This is the area.
Is it?
Oh, I think this is a shortcut.
Like a...
Like a little shortcut area.
I think this is where you're supposed to find the lever handle.
Isn't that...
Don't let it see you.
Oh, yeah.
Ah, okay.
Okay, so like...
That should be easy.
We could use one of us as bait.
Good idea.
You should go.
As the idea person here.
If I die, who else will have all these good ideas?
He's gone, I think.
I don't see him.
Oh, okay.
He hears your footsteps?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, okay.
What did this book say?
You know, like...
Okay, we look like that character in Pigment.
Oh, I think he's done.
Wait.
Oh.
Ah!
I can't!
No!
Ah!
Oh, my God!
No!
The monster crush do be on top of my body, so I couldn't move!
I couldn't...
I couldn't get away!
It was...
He's...
He's the Costco guy!
I get...
I get poor big boobs!
Big boobs!
Boo!
Okay.
How do we do this?
We just...
We gotta go right...
Don't let him see us!
Yeah!
He's got all of us!
That's crazy!
Yeah!
He had to be fair!
I was just standing there!
We were just standing there!
Maybe he wouldn't get me if I just stood still!
Can he hear a microphone?
Does that play?
Oh, that's true!
No, it says don't let it see you, though!
No, it also said he hears your footsteps, though!
Oh, okay!
So we just have to crouch!
Yeah, I think so!
Okay, be very, very quiet!
I'm hunting wabbits!
Wabbits, yeah!
I wanna see where this line goes!
Be very...
Be very quiet!
Be quiet!
Okay, I think, like, he does go back and go forward, so, like, we just gotta wait for him to do that, right?
Yeah, we know that it's a dead end now, but we can open up this!
Yeah, which we did, didn't...
Open the door!
Thank you!
Oh, my gosh!
He had me!
Alright...
We just gotta wait for him to come back, and then he'll, like, go forward.
Oh, right, yeah, because we have to make the first right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we have to...
Yeah, yeah, and then he did come back!
But I think he'll see us here, right?
There's no way...
Oh, wait, no, there was a...
No, no, no, because, like, Nimi ran up to him, remember?
Oh, that's...
That's right, that's right.
Yeah, so, maybe he's, like...
You know, like, there's some animals that can't see, like, more than, like, five feet?
You can hear him coming, too.
Like, things just get...
It's like how, like, crocodiles can't see in front of them.
Oh, there you go, see?
Let's shimmy over.
Okay.
Guys, I don't think we should be in the dead end.
Oh, there was a thing here.
Oh, did we turn our flashlights off?
Okay.
Okay, guys, I think this is a bad idea.
I think we should have went forward.
Should we go?
What?
You didn't have to follow me!
You were the leader!
Wait, maybe we're fine.
Maybe we could...
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're fine?
Maybe he jumped out the window.
Yeah, maybe he could.
Yeah, yeah.
You know what?
I believe that.
Maybe he jumped off the building.
He didn't jump off the window!
He didn't jump...
Yeah!
Everything is fine.
I'm okay.
I'm alive!
I'm so alive!
Am I the only one left?
I'm alive!
No!
I'm okay.
Is it just me?
Am I the only one left?
Okay.
Everything is okay.
I'll be a hero.
Oh.
I'm gonna be a hero.
Don't worry, I'll go where no one has gone before.
Oh my god, where am I?
Where am I?
What is all of this?
Oh!
I'm stuck!
Is there nowhere else to go?
Is this...
No, it's fucking closed!
No!
I missed it!
Nobody sees me here, right?
I'm the main character, baby!
I'm the main character.
I'm lost.
I think it's here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
I did it!
Oh my god, I did it!
I saved the run!
Oh yeah.
Alright.
Okay guys, I did it!
Guys, I'm a hero.
You're welcome.
It's like, surprise!
To be honest, I didn't have any faith in you.
That's right!
Bro, when he was like in...
I was just up here in the corner, and he just walked past me.
Yeah!
You're a gay man.
Oh my god.
We're outside now, yeah!
I think they're gone.
I think they're inside.
You better hide!
What?
What does that mean?
But we're outside!
I'm hiding!
Oh!
I'm gonna hide!
Whoa!
Doobie,
why didn't...
Doobie, why did you...
Why did you just stand there?
Okay, it's okay.
I believe it, man.
Where did he... Where did they come from?
What are they supposed to do?
Get into the library.
Is it like she just came from the gate, killed all of us, and then left?
He just... Why did he just leave?
I think it is.
Fire inside.
Oh, yeah, we're live!
Crazy.
What's that?
What happened?
We just...
I don't know.
I was stunlocked because Doofy was like not moving.
I was changing a setting.
I was trying to fix something.
When died or others, the players become one in the... Oh, wait.
This is like basically how to revive people.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
What was that thing, though?
I don't know.
That was crazy.
Spider, right?
Yeah, it was a giant head spider.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, we can carry three items.
Yeah, that's good to know.
Yeah, yeah.
I feel like we just have to follow the line.
Storage of electrical... Okay, we need... Oh, wait.
We have electrical boxes?
Oh, where'd you get those?
Electrical boxes and apply them to empty slots of electrical circuits.
I have a computer.
Oh, nice.
Steal it.
That's good.
We can sell it on eBay.
Yeah.
New for me.
We gotta provide power to the door.
Alright.
But I have one of the electrical... Oh, there you go.
I found one.
Yeah, I found an empty slot.
Oh, I found it.
It's like they're like little squares on the thing.
You see it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you gotta like apply it.
Okay, okay.
Is there another one here?
Oh, one here.
One on me.
Oh.
Here.
Okay.
One here.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, there has to be another one.
Where did you find the first couple?
Oh.
We put that in here.
Oh, is there any more?
Oh, there's one here.
But we don't have any more electrical boxes.
We need to...
Maybe it's outside.
Oh, wait.
Maybe like...
We have to unlock...
Cause like...
We have to unlock another area.
Maybe.
Oh, yeah.
I like it.
Maybe we have to unlock this door first.
Is there one we can take from...
From the other side?
I'm gonna check all the others.
Cause I think we have to unlock the...
The door.
The...
The door on the left...
The right side.
Okay.
I'm gonna take this one.
One...
I have one more.
I took it from the other side.
Is there one that hasn't been put on?
Looks like a Wii.
Oh, here.
Okay.
No, no.
I think we gotta do this one first.
Oh, okay.
Like a puzzle or something.
Oh, my gosh.
We gotta think.
Use our brains.
There's two more here on this side.
Wait, but why...
No, I think we have to do the...
But why would we have to do the right side first?
Oh, wait.
This doesn't go anywhere.
Yeah, I don't know where it all leads up.
I thought it was to this door.
I think it's all connected.
I think we have to do this side.
This wall first.
I think we have to do the left side first.
Your precious computer.
Your computer!
The gaming PC!
Okay.
I'm gonna do the left side.
That's an item in my pocket.
Okay.
Uh...
I have one extra for this side, but is there anything else?
We can put it on.
I
found a storage.
There's two electrical boxes in this crate.
Oh!
Wait, can we crawl through here?
You just yoink it?
Yay.
We have to make the line green.
Wait, why is it not turning green?
Oh.
Maybe cause...
Oh!
Cause it's all connected!
I'm so dumb.
It's all connected.
Yeah, I think so.
Over here, over here, over here.
Wait, where?
Over there?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I see it, I see it.
Yeah, now it should all be connected.
We just missed that one.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Yay!
We did it!
We solved the puzzle!
Yay!
Our brain screwed three times that day.
Alright.
There was a monster running around over here.
Wait, install the monitor.
Really?
That's what this monitor's for!
Do me your time!
Your time!
It's your time to shine!
Oh, right here?
No, this is input device one.
Wait, do we need the transmitter?
Uh-oh.
No, no, I have one of the devices.
I wanna play with this puzzle.
You guys can't.
I'm done with this toy.
I wanna play with this new toy.
I believe in you.
Alright.
Wait, yeah, actually, please do that.
Yeah, we'll watch- We'll watch Doobie solve this puzzle.
No pressure!
No pressure or anything!
No, no, no!
All three of us are watching right now.
You got this.
Maybe I messed it up.
No, you didn't.
No, yo.
I believe in you.
I'm gonna start backseating.
Yeah, me too.
I think it's a pie.
Yeah.
Streamer, why didn't you move that tile shape down there?
You have to slide it.
Oh my god.
You just had it.
I would slide it.
Too realistic.
Move that one.
Streamer, you should've moved the other one.
You just had it.
You had the- Oh my gosh.
Streamer, why did you do that?
I solved it in two seconds.
Yeah.
Um, my child was able to solve this.
Oh!
I knew she could do it.
Wait, is that a Ouija board?
A Luigi board?
At chat, where's the ghost?
I think we need a table.
I think- I'm pretty sure we have to move forward, right?
There's a- there's a monster running about.
So, uh, we can go outside.
Um, you know.
I mean, we could come back here.
What's the book do?
Oh, I said- I don't know where- There's like that one room.
Yeah, yeah.
Remember that office we unlocked?
They said we could, like, keep it.
So, like, maybe there's gonna be a safe room or something.
We could just put it there.
Yeah.
I'll- I'll read it.
I'll bring the- I'll bring the special board.
We gotta go.
To install this, we have to defeat the monster.
No.
I'm scared.
Wait, what- Is there something outside?
I saw it run in the hallway upstairs.
Oh, there's a safe spot.
Oh, nice.
In the halls.
Yeah.
Alright, we're all here.
Oh, this is- Yeah, this is- Wait.
This is- Isn't this the elevator we went down to the basement before?
Oh, so we have to go back.
Yeah.
Oh, we go back.
Oh, then we, like, plug in these for the- the- our room.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh.
Our sweet gaming room.
Did you hear that?
Wait, the cat's gone!
The cat no!
Where did the cat go?
Wait, this is where I saw the monster running around.
Look at the snake!
He ate it!
Oh!
It looks really cute!
It's a- I mean, it looks really cute.
It's an ink monster.
Yeah, look.
It looks so cute.
Look at him.
Aw, he's friendly!
Look, guys!
Do you think it ate the cat?
What's that?
What is that?
That's a robot waifu?
Wait, what?
Yeah, you see her?
Oh, she is kinda weeny.
Oh, wait!
Oh, shit!
Yeah!
That's scary.
You guys shouldn't get too close.
Oh.
She's like that- like the girl version of that Resident Evil gal.
Hey, you looking for something, too?
Oh, yeah.
Something like that.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, I'm looking for a- a partner.
She's like the- the guy in Resident Evil 2.
Oh, what are you buying?
No, no, no, no, no.
Is it Resident Evil 2?
The guy that chases you that- in the trench coat.
But like a girl version.
Wait, what is- what did we give her?
The moon?
How can the moon even be there?
Oh, I have the keyboard.
Yeah.
The worm is being really noisy behind me.
I don't like it.
It sounds really weird.
Oh, this is Mrs. X!
Wait, she has anime eyes!
Look at her eyes!
It's like the how to- how to draw anime.
New objective!
Find out the password.
Use chat with the manager.
Oh!
Yeah!
Get out of here!
That's chat!
He's like streamer, why?
Aw!
Hey guys, I'm here to help with that puzzle from earlier!
Oh, chat's following a chat- I feel bad!
I thought Wordle.
You're like Wordle?
How do we find the password?
Use chat with a man- What the fuck does- At chat, what's the password?
He's in here!
He's making the ground nasty!
You're disgusting!
You're an outside pet!
Take that out!
You're not an indoor pet- hurts moreh we out- Oh yeah!
He's back!
Oh my God!
What happened?
This was your fault, man.
You made fun of him.
Look what you did, man.
He got angry.
You did this.
Oh, my God.
Did they die?
Wait, we can revive her up here.
We can revive her.
Right?
Oh, wait, no.
We can revive her.
Up top, up top.
We have to revive her.
She went the wrong way.
Oh, welcome back.
Hold on, I gotta get the monitor.
I dropped it.
Wrong way.
No, no.
Is it the elevator?
I don't remember.
No, we went this way before.
I think we just got unlucky.
Oh, we... Oh, okay.
Yeah, we just... Doobie literally went over and then just slammed on.
Yeah, but this is one for the team.
It's like, where did it come from?
I thought I heard it.
Alright, never... Don't make chat angry, man.
The worm is not friendly.
He was friendly.
Just ignore him.
He was friendly until you got mean to him.
You were so mean to him.
Okay, wait, I'm gonna... I'm gonna talk to the anime girl again.
Yeah.
Guys, he's coming.
He's out his way.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I don't need to tell you to shower.
Why are you so tall?
Don't look at him.
Don't even look at him.
Yeah, don't look at him.
Don't look at him.
Boob.
Enter the password.
What's a four letter.
What's a four letter?
Think it opened doors.
The password is eight zero zero eight.
Boob.
There's no letters.
I mean, there's no numbers.
We can do regular.
B, O, V.
Wait, is it?
Yeah, we could just do actual boob.
Yeah, just actually write boob.
Wait.
How do we tell our manager?
Just chat with the manager.
Yeah.
How do we... You think it's moon?
Somebody has to go woo the manager.
Who's the manager?
I want to speak to your manager.
Oh, there.
Oh, I got it.
Wait, what was it?
What was the password?
It was moon.
Oh, the transmitter.
Wait.
Button.
Oh, no, the transmitter.
Where is it?
Right here.
No, I'm real.
Oh.
Where is he?
He disappeared.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He poofed himself.
He disappeared.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You wait.
Did you be live?
Did you close?
Hide, hide, hide, hide, hide.
He's just sore, go door.
He's just sitting there.
You guys all ran, so...
I thought that was Doobie coming out of the other door, but it was a bad guy.
It was a very bad man.
Wait, guys.
No, I'm... Is it like... Remember when we were holding a transmitter earlier?
Yeah.
Where did we left that?
Where did we leave?
We should go save somewhere.
I think so, too.
Yeah, okay, but where did we leave the transmitter?
It's in the van at the start.
No.
It can't be that far.
Okay, we gotta retrace our steps.
I think it was in the basement, though.
Yeah, no.
It had to be.
We left items.
Oh, I think it was when... I think it was at the very beginning of the basement.
Okay.
Remember when, like... It was easy, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, with the man.
With the slam dunker.
Well, he's upstairs now, so... Oh, okay.
Well, we just have to... Okay, we... One of us just has to live.
Okay.
All right, I'll stay here.
We're dead.
It's all on YouTube.
It's on.
Wait, how would Doobie know when we're dead?
Wait, how would... What if Chai comes back?
Okay.
I'm gonna crouch walk.
We'll be fine.
Okay, but how... Yeah, I was gonna say... How would Doobie know when we're all dead?
When we never come back.
We just... It's just... She waits an hour alone in the room and was like, guys, I think she might be dead.
Yeah.
All right.
Where is she?
Where was... Oh, there was a safe right at the bottom here.
Yeah, yeah.
So, you could just... Yeah.
I remember that, too.
The monster probably can't be in the safe point.
He probably is.
Yeah.
I can't believe that it's not, like, a safe point.
Like, it's a safe point, but it's not a safe.
It's not safe.
It's not a safe room.
Yeah.
There is no safe room.
Okay, let's save.
Yeah, the room feels pretty safe.
All right.
Game has been safe.
We all died in here from the ink blob.
Oh, yeah.
If someone didn't piss him off... Wait, where's... Where's Doobie?
He got pissed off again.
Doobie?
Oh, wait.
Did Doobie crash again?
Doobie.
Oh, I hear him.
Oh, no.
Not here.
Doobie.
Doobie, Marco.
Oh, it's, like, bat.
Whoa, what's going on in there?
Oh, there's an evil creature out there.
Do you see that?
The one that's 12 feet tall?
Yes.
No.
Stand right where I'm standing.
Oh, it's the cat.
Is that a cat?
Yeah.
It has red eyes.
So, it must be evil.
All cats are evil.
He's scanning.
No!
Guys, don't look for you!
Oh, no.
Wait, where's Doobie?
Do you think he got her?
Do you think... Doobie!
No, because her body would be coming after us.
Hi!
Oh, no, no!
I hear her!
She's like, here!
Hello!
Oh, there you are!
Alright, we go this way.
We're gonna go in the basement.
Alright.
Easter egg found.
Basement number two.
Wait, now where's Mint?
Oh, I didn't know you guys were waiting for me.
Sorry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's okay.
It was in basement number two.
Yeah.
Alright.
Don't let him on the elevator.
Yeah, don't let the...
No boys allowed in the elevator.
Yeah, for the transfer.
Yeah, it was like, right here.
This is where you all died.
And I lived.
Oh, yeah, here it is.
Okay.
And became a hero.
It was like, to the right.
Oh, he's there.
He's there.
Okay, one of us...
One of us has to live.
Only one of us has to live and also grab the transmitter.
I don't see if I left it over here.
No, it was like when all of us died in that pile.
I'm just checking.
Just being very sure.
I think it is in that hallway where we all died.
I think so too.
Yeah, it is.
I think it's where we first initially died.
Yeah.
And it...
Like, cause I never came back.
So it's by the dead end area.
Yeah.
No, it's the...
I'll go.
It's the right side.
Yeah, no, it's the right side.
Yeah, the first dead end on the right.
Oh, over there?
Oh, you do?
I got it.
Alright, yeah, now we go back!
Let's go, let's go, let's go before he sees us.
Wait, which way is up?
Um...
Oh, this way, this way, this way.
Right here, right here.
Okay, that's...
I like how all of us ran past the elevator.
Is this all we needed?
There wasn't something else?
No, no, it was just a transmitter.
Okay, yeah.
We just accidentally...
Wait, wait, we can summon items that we have had before?
I don't think so.
This whole chat's not here anymore.
Okay, make sure we all save.
Nice.
Yeah.
Okay, then...
This way.
Oh, this way.
Yeah, yeah.
You okay?
I just hiccup...
Alright.
Screams.
Doesn't elaborate.
Alright.
What about the sexy lady?
Should we invite her?
We're gonna transmit it to her.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't think we speak the same language.
Insert...
Oh.
What else do we have to do?
Oh, it's transmitting data?
Okay.
I put it in her butt.
Um, I mean...
Oh.
I got her!
I scored!
I scored the woman!
Oh my god, Riz!
She's...
She's mine!
She's not with me!
Wow!
Miss!
You Riz'd her!
I Riz'd her!
I said...
Dot, dot, dot...
And she followed...
She went silent.
Yeah.
Dot, dot, dot.
Ooh!
That's pretty spicy.
Oh, she's talking.
She's talking.
Let's go there.
Explore the secret passage.
Secret passage?
Oh!
She's...
She's leading us!
Wait, what do we do in the wall?
I'm gonna take this transmitter?
I don't know.
She has to duck.
I think we used it.
Yeah.
I think you could keep it in here, probably.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Let's follow the top...
Look at her go.
The tall, big, strong woman.
It's a...
It's a runway now.
Yeah.
Help!
It's America's Next Top Model.
Oh!
No!
Oh, she disappeared!
She got sucked in!
Wait, there's a monster in here, then.
She got...
There is?
There's a guy right there.
Oh, there's him!
There's the big guy.
Yeah.
I'll see you.
Be careful.
Yeah.
Wait, should we save right here?
There's a safe place.
Oh, yeah, we should.
Yeah, yeah, let's see.
Yeah, yeah.
Come back, come back.
Unless we don't see the big, strong lady again.
We're good.
Okay, good.
Okay.
It was all a dream.
Oh, he's walking over here.
Yeah, he's coming this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He just left.
Alright.
I see her outside.
Oh, she's outside?
She's waiting for us in the rain.
Yeah.
That's so cute.
Yeah, I wanna see.
What?
She wants...
She wants to see her girlfriend.
Oh, I see her.
Yeah, she's over there.
Wait, I hear something.
Doobie, what are you looking at?
Is that her?
Yeah, that is her.
What's her?
Oh.
He's just out there.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, he's walking around.
Oh.
I think we have the couch, right?
Yeah.
As long as he doesn't see us.
Our anime girlfriend.
Oh.
Guys, I don't think Doobie lived.
We can go save.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, where's Doobie?
Wait, wait, wait.
Not A.
I think it got respawned.
I thought it got a A.
Hey!
Hey, that's weird that it let us...
I literally died the moment Nimi responded, you guys.
Yeah!
He's like right there.
Hold on.
Oh, yeah.
He's tough.
He's a big strong man.
Whoa.
Yeah.
He's out here getting ready for basketball.
Oh.
He scares me.
Alright.
Shining in his eyes.
Yeah.
He looks like an actual imposter.
He looks like...oh, he looks like Slenderman.
Yeah.
Explore the hole in the wall to the outside.
He does look like Slenderman.
So we gotta go outside.
Alright.
Somehow.
Oh, gosh.
I think he sees one of us.
I have to go.
I have to be nearby.
I was a volume in the end for all everything.
Is the volume okay?
Okay.
I think he can hear us.
I'm back.
Yeah.
Guys, did you hear me when I said I think...
Did you guys heard me when it said?
Seize one of us.
Did you not?
He cannot powerslide in this.
Famous last words.
Okay, I believe.
Nimi's so brave.
You go, Nimi.
Got Nimi.
No, Chat got her!
Chat got her!
Oh my god!
Yeah, look!
I see Nimo!
Can you get me?
No!
Yeah, come over!
We gotta bring her back!
What is that?
Alright.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god, he was trying to get me!
Wait, do you guys hear that?
You hear footsteps, right?
Yeah, do you guys hear that?
I heard it last time, too.
Hello.
Okay, alright.
Alright.
Did you have got grabbed by Chat?
No, no, it was the big guy.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, he's going through the wall!
He's got tentacles through the wall!
Wait, maybe I'll stay here and distract him.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, actually he went back, I think.
Oh, no.
Okay, I think, okay, I got a plan.
One of us has to be bait, and then the rest just runs over.
Go to the other room, you can open the door there.
Yeah, yeah.
Just one of us has to live.
Only one of us has to live.
I mean, if we all die, we just go...
We spawn right back at that safe spot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so there.
Only one of us has...
Okay, I feel like we have to go in the fort.
Okay, no, I...
Okay, Doobie, you be the hero.
Go, Doobie, go!
Okay, I don't think she...
Okay, yeah.
Oh!
Hello?
Hey?
Hey.
Oh, hey, guys.
We all live.
Yeah, but...
Where do we go?
Yeah.
It says we're supposed to go outside, but...
It's a little maze.
There's supposed to...
There's supposedly a map.
Oh, he's over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a little maze.
Oh, you can go through stuff here!
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
I'm outside!
Oh, God.
Don't go outside.
There's...
No, there's...
There's something in there.
There's...
There's a monster in front of us.
Okay.
Get in.
I don't know where to...
Let me be a hero!
I'll be a hero!
Let me just go!
Just go!
Okay, just go!
Wait!
Oh, he's gone.
He's gone.
We're fine.
Where do I go?
Can anyone see me?
Why?!
How did she live?!
I...
I didn't...
I didn't need to live!
Wait, is this the third floor?
Oh, he's here!
How many?
Is there a save room?
Save!
Oh, no!
Nimi doesn't know where the save is!
I don't know how to turn off the flashlight!
I...
Nimi!
How did you live?!
You were the chosen one!
Oh, I think it's open...
That was so scary!
Oh, I know it didn't save.
We didn't save it.
I don't...
But I don't think we need that door as long.
We know how to go outside.
That's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it would be good to open it, though.
Just in case.
All right, okay, okay, so...
All right.
So, all DBS has to do is lure him again, and then one of us opens the door.
Okay, I think I've improved my luring...
Uh...
Skill.
Yeah.
Oh, everybody...
If you...
All right, I got the door!
All right, we just gotta save.
In this room, see?
Yeah.
All right, when we save, we can save Doobie.
Yeah, yeah, let's save Doobie.
Yeah.
All right, we know how to go outside now.
Yeah, yeah, we know.
Okay, so Nia, where the fuck did you go, Nia and me?
Like, how did you live?
I couldn't find the...
The third floor.
Oh, he's...
Oh, wait, we can go first.
I don't know where to go, so I'll let you guys go.
Yeah, it's like forward and right.
I made it.
Okay, who died?
I think so.
Guys, there was always three of us, right?
Uh-oh.
The other thing is there.
It's okay.
I think Nimi went forward from here and then...
Yeah, yeah, I don't know where she went.
Oh, she's the only one that knew where to go.
Yeah, she was.
She was the only one.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, but that thing was not like...
It didn't kill us.
Yeah, see?
It probably will if it catches up to you.
Oh, God.
Yeah, see?
He's just friendly.
Oh, we found it.
Nice.
Good job, Doobie.
There's a guy right here, though.
He's right here.
Just run, just run, just run, run!
He'll kill one of us!
He'll only kill one of us!
He'll kill me!
We all made it, guys!
We all made it!
There were the little inky guys in here.
Guys, we all made it!
We all...
Let's just find a save point.
Yeah.
Ow!
There's a really loud sound in here!
I can't remember.
Yeah, I knew it.
It's me.
I'm dead.
Goodbye, world!
Goodbye!
Don't lock me out.
Where's Doobie, though?
Where's Doobie?
Oh, wait!
Doobie found a save point!
She found a save point!
She's trying...
She's trying to save!
She's trying so hard to save!
Where are you, Doobie?
Doobie!
Doobie, why?
Doobie, we don't know where the save is!
Where is she?
Maybe in the computer room.
I'm gonna...
Are you guys alive?
Yeah, yeah.
We saw you spamming the save.
Save right here.
Save, save, save.
Yay, you're back.
I got too many.
When you're scared, we start forgetting.
Oh, there's a gun.
Oh, wait, that's how you remove this?
Someone said, it said... There's a... There's a... Let's chat.
Oh, hey.
TV head.
Oh, it's a friendly.
Who are you?
I'm a TV head.
I don't think he's friendly.
Sometimes I want to... an orange to replace.
Oh, he wants an orange.
Oh, nice.
Signals on... To do this, the brightness of the monitors need to be changed.
Okay.
Don't make chat angry.
Oh, this mon... These?
Why did they send me here?
I saw a monitor.
I picked one up.
They said we gotta, like, make it match.
You guys have... Does anybody else have a monitor?
Uh... No, I don't have another one.
I saw one.
Um, in another room where we hid.
Oh, yeah.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Let's head over.
It's, like, right over here.
Yeah.
See?
That should be it.
Yeah, we have to remove it.
Just want to make sure there's... nothing.
I found the...
I found another way.
Like, a little...
hallway with a door.
There's a monster outside, apparently.
Wait, what else do I have to do next?
Wait, did you place the monitor?
I didn't have a monitor.
Wait, do we have?
I have a monitor.
Oh, hey, right here, right here.
Wait, where do I place it?
Right here.
Okay.
What?
Oh, gosh.
Wait, it is the cat.
There he is.
It's coming our way.
It's okay.
He doesn't kill you.
See?
It's, like, a little ride.
Oh, guys, I don't think this monitor matches.
Wait, how do we solve this puzzle?
A wall of black liquid.
There is, like, a...
I found a hole somewhere.
Like...
Wait, follow me, guys.
There's a hole with a monster.
A hole with a monster.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what's this?
Green electrical.
Where the fuck does this go?
No, um...
There was a red line, like, at the very beginning where we were in the stairwell.
Oh!
Can we just put it...
Can we just put this in here?
Oh, we can't.
No, that's the trading machine.
Okay, so...
Yeah.
We have to hold on to this, then.
Okay, I found, like...
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Follow me, guys.
There's a little hole...
With a...
With a monster.
But, like, I think it's the next area.
I'm gonna check the red line.
Alright.
Okay.
Did you just sit?
I'm so scared.
You sat down.
Guys, I need a moment.
I need a moment.
Uh-oh.
Um...
Okay, I'm sorry.
Look at the goo monster.
I don't care.
I just need a moment.
What is this?
Oh, nice.
Power's on.
We did it.
We gotta go revive, doobie.
Oh, the doobie died?
Oh, we got the monitor!
Five!
Whoa!
Oh, there's the puzzle!
We're gonna get a gun once we...
Okay, it's...
That...
Wait, how do you turn it gray?
Yeah?
Come, we've revived doobie.
Alright.
There we go.
Hello!
I'll come back.
Alright, we gotta do this.
Oh...
One, two, three, four, five.
I got the left side.
Oh...
What do you mean?
What is it?
Okay.
Computers?
Yeah.
Yeah, if you turn one off, some of them turn...
I got the left side, and he went to do the right.
Yeah.
Oh, this is the gray.
We got it!
We did?
No.
Yeah.
Oh.
Uh...
Gray, gray...
Wait.
Isn't that not correct?
Oh, wait.
No, this has to be white.
Oh...
What if I do this?
This is...
No, no, no, no, no.
I thought they were all supposed to be on.
Oh, it's different colors!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then this should be black.
Yeah, he's funny looking.
And then...
Hello.
Hint to the puzzle?
Oh, he'll give us a hint!
Oh, nice!
Wait, what?
Hmm...
Here we go.
I think...
Oh, gosh.
You need to...
It just says you need to match it.
Singles...
Okay.
They're like, you just gotta match it.
Wait a minute.
Oh!
We have to follow the line!
Each line corresponds to a square!
So this one is...
Okay, this one's correct.
Is it?
I don't...
I don't even correspond...
Yeah.
Check the line.
I'm checking the line.
The first computer is good.
Which computer is this one?
We're missing the second one.
Yeah, it's a lot of lines.
Is this correct?
Okay.
We got this one correct.
Oh?
Okay.
Oh!
Okay!
I figured it out.
Um...
Wait, wait.
Are you pressing the buttons on it?
Wait.
Uh...
I can put it back to what it was before.
Sorry.
Can you do that monitor on the right side?
And I'll tell you if it's correct or not.
Okay, this one?
Yeah.
Keep pressing.
Yeah, there you go.
Next one.
Huh?
Wait, can you keep pressing?
Yeah.
Next one.
Okay.
Yeah.
Next one.
Yep.
Oh!
Keep pressing.
Yep.
Next.
Yeah.
Okay, we're missing one more.
I guess it's the one on this side.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
We did it!
Yay!
We're the smart.
How does it...
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
There's no fire.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The shadows.
We're the smart blondes.
Wait, I can get one too!
Oh, nice!
Oh, no, I think the only one...
We did it!
You see?
Wait, should we save?
Let's save.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we're the smart blondes.
Yeah.
The greens were just...
Where'd you guys go?
We're the greens were just...
I'm not even wearing this.
We're getting back away as we found our electrical box!
I heard you giggled...
Yeah, I heard you giggled...
Yeah, that's right!
Where!
Oh, yeah.
Nah, they don't...
They can't be shot.
Alright, let's go.
Maybe they're tamed.
They're like, uh, domesticated.
Yeah, domesticated chat.
You're well behaved now.
Yeah, we're well behaved.
There's an electrical box on the roof up there.
Oh yeah, okay.
I know how to get there.
I know how to get there, but I want to shoot the shadows first.
Okay.
It's over here.
It's less scary when there's like, you know...
When there's light.
Yeah!
We did it!
Wow, that actually worked!
Okay, but here, follow me.
There's like another... Look.
Follow me.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, did you get the goo?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here.
Oh, wait, wait, no.
This goes into the classroom.
Wait, here, here, here.
This one.
This guy.
There's something evil out there.
Yeah, that's what I saw.
I can't shoot him.
Did that work?
No.
I don't know what...
Oh, it's just for the wall, right?
I don't know what this is for though, because...
There he goes.
Oh, he just jumped the other room.
I don't know what this is for.
Because our objective is...
It's for the wall.
Didn't we get the wall?
Yeah, no, no, the wall.
No, that's not the wall.
The wall's behind us.
Whoa!
Alright, well, let's go back.
Yeah, I'm going back.
Yeah, he's a little dangerous.
Do we have a wall too?
Yeah, we have...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's over here.
Yeah.
Right here.
Doobie, doobie, doobie.
This is it.
We're the next guy.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll do that.
We'll do that for...
Oh,
okay.
Okay, so that's the...
I got an achievement.
Meet the monster on...
Guys, I think...
I think Min met the monster.
I think she...
I think I can hear us.
I did not.
Are we safe?
Do you think?
It's coming back.
Oh...
It's just turning around.
I don't think I can keep coming in here, right?
I don't think so.
I think he's too thick.
Oh, I closed...
Yeah, he's too thick.
I closed the door.
Okay.
Did Nimi make it?
I don't know if Nimi made it.
I know Min's definitely dead.
I know she's dead dead.
I saw them both get run over.
Like, they both got hit with a bus.
Oh, okay, so we have to, like, run past it when he...
Okay, I'll go on the other side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay,
when he does the loop, we run.
We have to wait for him to do the loop.
Okay, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Doobie?
Did Doobie go?
Oh my god, Doobie's going the other way.
Doobie, why?
Why, Doobie, you'll never make it!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, Doobie made it!
Doobie made it!
Can't see, it's too dark.
Oh,
radio.
Hello?
What is Doobie doing?
I wonder if this is useful.
What about, wait?
I can't hear the ghost.
Yay, that's my radio!
How do I make it so I can hear you guys?
Is everybody dead?
Oh, I'm back!
Yay!
Okay.
Okay, so...
He does turn around, he turns around.
I found out.
He does?
Yeah, so we have to let him run a little bit and then...
Oh, you can have the gun.
Nah, it's okay.
Alright, and then like, and then run.
I was wondering how you died.
I found Doobie for two seconds.
I know, me too!
Yeah, he turns around.
I think we can run from here, right?
Maybe?
I just wait until he turns the corner.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll wait for a little bit.
I'm just so loud.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Run, go, go, go, go, go!
The door.
The door!
The the door!
We're okay.
We're safe here.
Doobie?!
Where's Doobie?
Wait.
Oh, Doobie called Antzou.
I hear!
Nice!
Hello!
Okay.
Oh, complete the... on the third floor.
Wait.
The one on the wall is over here.
Wait, there's a hole, there's a hole, there's a hole!
Wait, what is this?
Wait, what?
Come shoot the goo.
Wait, where?
It's... Where is it?
Right here, right here.
Where is it?
Oh.
Wait, where?
I don't see a goo anywhere.
No, no, no.
Out here, out here, out here.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
Show me.
Right here.
Wait, behind you.
There you go.
All through the window.
Through the window, through the wall.
Where was the electrical box?
Didn't we see one earlier?
Yeah, we did.
Did we use it for something?
Is that the exit?
Guys, I don't think we'll never find the moon, guys.
We're...
Okay, we have to go forward then?
I feel like we're making great progress.
Yeah.
Alright.
Still not at the moon.
Oh, oh, wait, I can... we can open this door.
Oh, wait, it's closed on the other side.
Oh, this is open this.
Oh, guys, I need someone to open that door.
Yeah, I got it.
Woohoo!
Ah!
We have that!
I was like, yay, guys!
We were gonna open the door, everyone!
Oh my God.
I was
like, we
did it!
Okay, I'm waiting for the loot.
I think we're too late.
Okay, okay, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Okay, someone else open that door.
Someone else open it.
I got it.
Okay, okay, we got the door, we got the door.
Okay.
Alright.
Careful, don't get run over.
The door's open.
I'm not, I'm not!
Alright, get the electrical panel.
We'll wait here.
Okay.
I wish we could observe her when she's alive.
Yeah!
Where would this...
Okay, we gotta figure out a link.
Oh, wait, we have to put it here.
Oh, she found it.
Vince found it.
Yeah.
She's gonna go get it right now.
Yeah, so then we're missing two after that.
Oh, okay.
What is this, anyway?
It's, uh, the electrical circuit.
The generator?
Yeah.
Maybe we put the electricity.
We have to go down.
Oh, wait, we can't go down.
Nice.
Alright, now we're just...
Maybe we go left side.
Oh, remember that...
Remember that giant guy that was jumping earlier?
I'm going forward.
Okay, we found another.
Oh, that's scary.
I don't like the sounds, guys.
Hey, guys.
I'm on the other side.
I'm trying to see if there's, like, any, uh, electrical circuits here.
I kept running.
Okay, okay.
Who tried to bait him earlier?
I know one of you guys tried to bait him.
Wait, is Doobie alive?
Did she live?
Wait, where's Doobie?
Oh, no.
He got me from inside!
I'm so sad.
Anybody?
Hello?
Oh, no!
Just knee me.
Only knee me.
Can you tell me she's dead?
The gun is right later?
Oh, hey, the light works!
Oh, hey!
You have to go all the way back for that safe point.
Where's the safe point?
I can't do this on my own!
Be a hero, D.V.
It's time to be a hero.
Oh!
You're a hero!
You did it!
Where are we?
Where is this place?
How did you get here?
Oh, wait!
I think this is where the guy crashed through the wall from.
Okay, we're still- Oh, I found a circuit!
Guys, guys!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, we need to find one more circuit area.
I have- Someone take it!
I only have guns!
I have a monster that was hiding, and the building is lurking on the- Oh!
I only have, um, I only have, uh, I can't pick it up because I have a gun.
Oh, sorry!
Someone else has to pick- Oh!
I got it!
Alright, we gotta figure out where this goes.
Wait.
I'm safe here!
It's safe here!
Uh, is it here?
No, no, no.
This is the door.
So we have to find- Oh, okay.
Where to put the green.
Okay.
We gotta make- wait for him to loop again.
Yeah.
Okay, and then make sure he doesn't turn around.
Turn around.
Yeah, we gotta turn around and fucking ate Doobie.
Go!
In here?
Maybe.
I don't- I don't think I saw one in here, but maybe- I mean, we could crouch here.
Phil.
Where the fuck is the line?
There's a line here.
Let me in.
He's gonna turn around again.
There's no line- I don't see a box here.
I don't either.
I don't want to go straight.
Alright.
Find the line.
Is there another line here?
No, it keeps going.
Okay.
So we'll wait here.
I can wait.
Okay, let's go.
Where's the line?
Oh, it's over here.
I see the line.
Oh.
What is this?
Is this Doobie?
Is this- Oh, it's Doobie.
Wait.
What happened to me?
Can we respawn them?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
Oh, oh, okay.
Yeah, respawn Doobie.
Yeah.
I know where the box is.
Thank you.
Okay, okay.
Okay, we're following.
Go, go, go.
Maybe not wait here.
Oh, I got it!
Oh, there's- Did I wait?
Yeah, yeah.
I think it'll loop.
It's gonna loop soon.
This is one electrical box.
Okay, I think- Remember that giant jumping thing all the way over there?
Yeah.
On the part, right?
I think that's where the last green box is.
It probably is.
Yeah, so I had to go back.
Wait, let's save real quick.
Let's save real quick since we're in the box.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
We just did that one, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Okay.
Nice.
We're gonna see the moon, guys!
We're gonna save the moon!
No moon!
Alright.
How does this lead to a rocket?
Oh my god.
It's gonna lead us to a rocket.
Alright.
We're gonna go to space with our- Yeah.
I'm going.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I'm gonna run into the safe spot.
Safe point.
Alright, I feel very safe in here.
Yeah, put on some gems, Doobie!
It's dead!
Because we're a team!
We all run out!
Doobie let him turn around with all the guys!
I think, like, the collision of your body is...
Because I didn't go outside.
When a collision hit you!
Okay, now go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
We're all fucking lemons, yeah!
Yeah, the 4 for 1 sale.
There we go, there we go.
Okay, okay.
4 for 1 sale.
5, 1, get 3, 3, 3.
Go, go, go, go!
We're gonna make it!
Oh my gosh.
We're gonna make it, we're gonna make it, we're gonna make it!
We're gonna make it!
Guys, I don't think...
I don't think you need...
Guys, don't worry, we can clone it!
We can doobie 19!
The last green circuit is here.
Wait, what if the radio is the key?
I don't think the radio is the key, guys, I... Oh, that's true, that's true.
Wait, but there wasn't... She died because of the radio.
What if, what if the sound distracts you?
Alright, do it.
Oh, he ran away.
He walked away.
Alright, I feel like we shouldn't stick close together.
Oh.
Sounds like a cat.
Sounds like that cat that goes like, that's eating.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
I don't want to die again.
I don't want to die.
Alright, well, we can't stick together because we got...
I don't think he sees us.
Mint, you're fine.
He didn't see us.
Be a hero, Mint.
Meow, meow, meow.
He's gonna jump soon.
I know,
but...
It's fine, we're fine here.
Wait, wait, we distracted him for Nimi.
We distracted him for Nimi.
Oh, we did not distract him for Nimi.
No, she's alive.
She's alive.
Did she get it?
She's a hero.
I'm a hero.
Quick.
She's a hero.
Scratch.
Alright, let's die.
Watch the slender man come back again.
Oh my god.
Wait, no, man, you hold it.
Man, you know where it is.
You know where it is.
Okay, we gotta wait for the loop.
We gotta wait for it.
No, no, don't be in here right now.
Oh my god.
She did it.
Crouch.
She did it fucking crouch.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, does she live?
Does she live?
No, no, she's alive.
She's alive.
I'm alive.
Oh my god.
Come here, come here.
Okay, we gotta save.
Yay!
We're heroes.
We'll remember your sacrifices.
For, for earth.
Okay.
You brought the radio.
Oh, we did it.
Okay, we, it's, it's all went across.
Wait, how did you get here?
We can save again.
Oh yeah, we gotta save again.
What?
We should save again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we should save again.
There's a door.
Oh, we should just go this way then.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Cause it's on the other side.
It's on the other side, though.
I'm gonna wait the loop.
I'm not risking it.
Me too.
Yeah.
We're smart.
Yeah, we're a yellow team.
Yeah, team yellow.
We use our brains.
Okay, let's go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
It's the left side.
No, it's, it's, it is...
Okay.
Alright, we'll see if Min lives.
We'll see if she lives.
She'll be okay.
Yeah, she's okay.
Okay.
It's like...
Right here, it's right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Nice, alright.
We did it!
We defeated the monster!
We gotta go to the moon!
Where's the moon?
We gotta go see the moon!
Wait, what's down here?
Hello?
Can we open this door?
Close from the other side.
No, we can't open that.
Then we go down then.
Down, down, down.
Oh, there's another one here!
Oh, I see.
River!
Instantly.
Oh, dynamite?
We need dynamite here?
We're that monster.
Oh, nice.
I'm shooting my goo.
That's right, shoot that white goo.
Oh, elevator!
Oh, there's a door!
There's a door!
Oh, my God!
It's your wife!
It's your wife, Min!
Where?
She's over here!
You made her!
See, I... Are you heading to the laboratory?
I need to get back.
I'm gonna...
Oh, she's gonna shoot the white... Oh!
I'm coming!
Oh!
Oh, that's my boy!
I couldn't help it!
I'm coming with... She's coming with us!
She's coming with us!
She's on the top!
You mean that you...
You gotta impress her with your moves.
I know.
Oh, yeah, I'm fine.
Let me show her.
Don't worry.
Oh, you see that?
Oh, let's all dance around here.
Oh, my gosh.
Jump down the elevator shaft?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's...
Hey, hey, lady.
Whoa!
Which one is that?
Wait!
The one...
Do you think she likes it?
Do you think...
I'm doing the robot here.
That's not the robot.
That is the Macarena.
Okay, someone has to press the elevator.
Alright, nice.
Oh, my God, her hair when we go down.
Oh, wow.
Damn, this elevator is fast, guys.
It's the fastest elevator ever.
Yeah.
Someone was like, this looks like a frat house.
Uh-oh.
Um...
There's some...
Wait, did we talk to her?
Oh, she doesn't want to talk to us.
She doesn't want to talk to you.
Oh, okay.
You talk to her.
Wait, no.
That's just a dead guy.
No, but there's another guy.
It looks like a clown.
There's a clown?
Are you afraid of clowns, man?
Look at him.
He's got really long arms.
Where?
Oh, wait.
There is a clown.
Oh!
It's...
They trapped him!
Whoa!
I didn't know this was that kind of dungeon.
Yeah!
Wait, wait.
Uh...
Oh, it's his brother!
That's right.
Dance number five on him!
What's dance number five?
That's someone's brother!
Let it rip!
That's right.
Someone's brother, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, weren't we here before?
Oh, no!
I think there's no...
Oh, wait, we were!
It's a silent killer.
Whoa!
Big room.
Why are we feeling about to go this way?
This is a...
Oh, we're here.
This is the same one we were in before.
Yeah, but then the guy died.
We have to go downstairs.
We have to find...
Maybe...
A staircase?
A scanner.
Oh.
Oh, nice!
There's a guy, there's a guy, there's a guy, there's a guy, there's a guy.
Oh, I think that's him.
Where do we go?
I think we're supposed to...
I don't know.
Down the laboratory.
We should keep going down somehow.
Yeah.
She didn't give us more instructions.
Hi.
Oh.
What is she telling you, Doobie?
This is a...
mandatory scam.
You guys don't need to watch this.
It's like...
You're the...
You know like the...
We're the booby inspectors.
I'm just trying to see what the scan thing does.
Oh.
Okay.
Who forgot to push the other button?
Who...
Who forgot to push the third button?
I didn't realize there was a basement to ruin.
We're not in the right area.
Whoops.
Sorry.
That was...
I'm a quick shot.
No time.
Whoa.
Greg,
the moon is locked in here.
Oh my god.
We're in Gru's laboratory, guys.
We're in Gru's laboratory.
What's the cat...
What's the cat doing with the moon?
Oh yeah.
The cat's staring at the moon.
Wait.
The...
The lady's gone.
Is that our girl?
Oh, there she is.
Yeah.
We can pee on the moon.
I caught the moon for you.
I don't know.
So this is the moon you are after?
Yeah.
You...
Kinda tiny, isn't it?
Um, some people say it's above average.
Okay?
Wait.
Do you guys see the little coronaviruses that are...
What?
Yeah.
Yes.
Did you see it, Mimi?
Did you see it?
Wait, wait.
Okay.
Don't worry.
They'll pass us by.
They'll pass...
I saw it.
Huh?
Yeah, there.
You see it?
The coronaviruses in here.
Oh no.
Guys, I don't wanna get COVID again.
I can't do it again.
Guys.
I got my shots.
What is this?
I toggled it.
Yes.
Oh.
Ew.
Something happened.
Oh?
I mean, we...
I don't think it's dangerous right now.
It does say explore.
Okay.
I mean, let's just explore and see.
Yeah.
These
are coming on.
Oh, yeah.
I see it.
It's not an elevator here.
Oh.
You know how to use that thing?
No, I...
Call the elevator.
No, it just shoots on its own.
Look at it.
Oh, wait.
Stop.
Oh, I'm controlling it.
Wait, you're controlling?
Oh.
Yeah, for some reason when I press the button, I let them do it.
Oh, cool.
Oh, no.
It's the same elevator.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we go in?
Is it?
It says first, second, and third.
Unless...
I mean, we could try.
Is there any other buttons left?
Is there anything else around?
Oh, this is a different elevator.
Oh.
Okay.
Chad's like...
Wireless gun.
My gun has blue teeth.
This is an electronic board.
Oh, so we have to go to...
Oh, yeah.
We'll go to the elevator.
Elevator, yeah.
Yeah.
It's just shooting.
On its own.
I need it.
It's Bluetooth wireless.
Oh.
What floor do we do?
Wait, do we need it?
Yeah, we might need it.
Get it out of here at all.
I don't like it.
No, me...
Doobie's controlling it.
I know, but it's in my head.
Okay, so dude, what floor do we do?
I'll do a second floor.
We need electric boards is what it says.
We need two of them.
Is this an electric board?
I think so.
Is that it?
It's a scanner.
It's a board.
Oh, it's a scanner.
Yeah, we're on a different floor.
Oh, okay.
Oh, this is where the...
I think this is a save point, guys.
Oh, nice.
Let's save it.
Okay, nice.
There's something appearing on my radar.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, maybe that finds the electric boards.
Wait, maybe it's the moon.
It's the moon.
Oh, I see it.
COVID's coming.
Oh, you're right.
What do you mean?
Award 2019, tell the COVID.
What happens when...
Can I shoot it?
They are.
Oh.
My aim.
Oops.
Were you able to shoot your white goo on it?
I'm trying to.
You need me to shoot.
I have performance anxiety.
Wait.
Maybe the right side?
Or we go forward.
Wait.
There's something over here.
What's that?
I just toggled something.
I don't know what happened.
Oh, I found it.
Oh, I found a lever.
Oh, wait.
The gate to the lower floor is locked by multiple levers.
They must be activated simultaneously?
What?
Okay.
I have a lever for one of them.
Wait.
How many are there?
There's four of us.
It's in...
I thought it was on another one, but it was just a reflection.
Oh.
Maybe it's on the other side.
Maybe the lever's on the other side.
Is there a lever over here?
Here comes COVID.
Oh no.
Wait, what are those?
They're little...
Oh, they're little guys!
What is that?
Okay, we found another one.
Oh.
Did you press yours?
No.
Wait.
I thought we had to push them at the same time.
Okay.
I'll do a countdown.
Do you guys hear me from here?
Do it really well.
Oh!
He's following me.
Do fake...
Do fake and angry?
Yeah.
Wait.
Is there a lever over there?
I have a lever...
Yeah, there is, there is.
Nimi's at a lever.
Okay.
Then...
You have that one, and then I have probably the one of...
Oh!
It's a second...
It's a five second cooldown!
Nimi!
Turn on your lever!
Don't press it yet.
Don't press it?
She said she'll shoot the gun when Nimi presses it.
Okay.
Do you think...
Not yet.
Um...
Do you think the bluetooth range fell off?
Oh!
Press it!
Did it work?
No.
Is it more...
There must be another lever, cause I have this.
Oh!
Remember, there's the one upstairs!
I think that...
Yeah, but...
Does that have to...
Also?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh!
Okay.
It didn't work!
Oh!
Nimi died.
Nimi died?
Yeah, Nimi's dead.
Apparently.
I think...
I think it got her.
Well, let's just go back upstairs and we got her.
No, wait.
There's a save area here, remember?
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is Doobie dead?
Yeah.
We did turn on the lever, it didn't work.
But I think there...
Is there another lever down here?
Because I do have...
Uh...
I do have this handle.
Well, wait.
Let's go check the third floor, too, then.
Yeah, but how are we gonna coordinate, like, all four, though?
That's the thing.
Yeah, cause don't you need everyone to be in the elevator to use it?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
He only has to kill one of us.
Oh, he's a little coward baby.
Yeah.
We got our shots.
Yeah, we got our shots.
Yeah.
It's scary.
Oh, it's like we're animals.
Yeah.
We got our...
We got our flea shots.
Yeah.
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
It went after me!
Uh-oh.
Did she make it?
I don't know.
It makes that...
It's making that sound, like...
I think she's...
Oh, she ran to the elevator.
Yeah.
You made it!
Let's just check the third floor, then, for now.
Okay.
Yeah, let's go...
Let's go down one more.
Cause I do...
I'm just gonna hold on to this lever, then, just in case.
Nah.
I'm gonna go through here just to see there's anything.
Alright.
Yeah, first floor.
We'll be back.
I'm here!
Wait!
Hey!
Yeah, did she just...
Did she just left us?
Wait, she actually went down the floor.
She...
I think she went up.
Or did she...
Wait...
No, she's coming up.
Yeah, she's coming up.
Wait...
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, she just left us.
It works without everybody being in the elevator.
Oh, that's good.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but how do we do the countdown?
Time to split up, gang.
And then do it when the clock strikes.
Wait, let's get our alarm.
Let's set up a alarm.
Sink our alarms.
Oh, yeah.
What is that?
What is this?
Yeah, this is what I saw before.
There's a mini.
It's a little die.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, there's a broken lever.
Here you go.
Documentation for the crystal.
The crystal made from an orange.
It glows with a bright orange pattern and emits orange particles that gradually fade away.
When the moon remains indoors for an extended period.
What is that?
We got it!
He accumulates at the bottom of the foam.
Meatball.
Aiding the ripening of oranges.
It's like a...
Wait, is this an orange?
Orange!
Yeah, for the TV!
Oh my god.
If you need to approach the area beneath the moon, please take the crystal with you and stay close to it.
Okay, so you gotta take him.
Gotta take him?
Take him!
It's my hand.
What do you?
Look at him.
He's just a little orange.
Has the gun always been in this position?
I don't know.
He's just very excited.
Alright, so we have all the lever...
How do we...
Aren't we gonna do the countdown for this?
Wait!
Oh, I know!
It shows a light!
It shows a light when someone presses it.
Oh, yeah!
So we can just...
Yeah, sing it up!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I call bottom floor.
Wait, we have the floor?
Alright, I'll do the first one.
I'll do the first one.
Bye!
Alright, give me...
Guys, I need to like, get tissues real quick anyway.
I'll be right back.
I also didn't want to go through...
I didn't want to go through the viruses again.
I need to blow my nose.
We can...
They...
Whoever has to do two and three...
Has to go through the most dangerous ones.
So...
I wonder if they...
They have to be close there.
I hear them a little bit.
Oh.
One more.
Oh, someone's not there.
No!
Okay.
Okay, I...
We fucked it up.
Okay.
We gotta wait.
No!
Stop!
Everyone stop!
We're hunting now!
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
I go first.
Okay.
Yes!
We did it!
Oh, and I...
Oh, we get to be at the bottom.
Yay!
They have to come back at the bottom.
Whoa, what?
What?
Oh, it's lethal.
We have to have the virus thing.
Come to the bottom, guys.
If you hear my voice, you have to be at the bottom.
We need the orange.
Yeah, yeah, there's a...
We need the orange, guys.
It's on the first floor.
It's at the very bottom.
We need our vitamin C.
We're so close to saving the moon.
Oh!
What's chat?
Wait, where's...
Where's Mitt?
Don't look at him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's like a little ring.
So, like...
As long as we're in the ring, we're safe.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
The moon.
I don't know how to trigger him.
If we look at him, do we trigger him?
I think so.
He probably has a meter if you look at him for too long.
Oh, that's true.
He doesn't like to be looked at.
Although, I feel like there was one time nobody was looking at him and he attacked us.
No, I'm pretty sure one of us looked.
One of us did it.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go.
Stay at the orange.
Stay in the orange.
Or we die.
Going this way.
Alright.
There's a cat.
Oh, look.
He's so cute.
Yeah.
What's this?
What is that?
Electronic board.
Oh, one of the boards we need.
Oh, nice.
Two more.
I'll try.
Run, run, run!
We gotta follow them, the orange!
Woo!
Oh my god, he got somebody.
He got someone.
Oh, it's down, it's down.
Is he satisfied?
Yeah, I think he's satisfied.
Wait, someone...
Is there a save down here?
Someone died to the moon.
I heard the boom sound.
Someone...
I think Min died to the moon.
I hope there's...
We gotta find a save.
I'm pretty sure it has to be.
Oh, there's an A.
There's an Easter.
Oh, no.
There's another one.
Wait.
Oh, there's more.
Did Min look at him?
Min must have looked at him.
Oh!
Wait.
What's this?
What are we pushing this to?
There's three of them now!
There's three!
One for each of us!
Oh!
No, not the moon!
The moon fires!
Oh, no.
They're gonna take our bodies.
We gotta find a save before they kill us.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's up the stairs.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Let's go up the stairs.
Yeah.
Okay.
We go.
I don't think they can go upstairs.
No, I don't think so, too.
They don't have the legs.
Oh, there's a save.
Oh, nice!
Let's go.
Welcome back!
I'm home!
Oh, they can go upstairs.
So, what happened?
Did the moon virus got you?
Yeah, I got got by the moon virus.
What happened?
Oh!
Yes, I do!
I do!
What is that?
I have the crystal.
I'm safe.
Oh, my God!
Wait.
I don't think we're safe with the crystal.
I don't...
I...
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, the moon virus...
The moon virus is infectious here!
What's this?
Wait.
Fully red, orange is right.
It's planted on it.
The new heal should take hold within...
What the fuck is that?
Hello.
Hello, chat.
Hello?
Is he still chasing you?
Welcome back, everyone.
Oh, hello.
No, no, no, no!
I don't want to be trying to...
I don't know what to do!
Open the safe box?
What's the safe box?
Capsule, capsule!
We gotta place the capsule!
What's the capsule?
What do we place it?
This, this, this!
What?
How do we...
We could push it?
What do we push it?
Oh, no!
See where the red light is?
We gotta push it down there.
Oh.
Push it with all our strength.
Right there, right there.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Okay, we gotta push the other one.
We gotta push the other one.
Okay, we have five more.
It was over on the other side.
Alright, where's the Shadow Man?
Okay, wait, wait.
Let's all get Doobie back, guys.
Guys.
Doobie.
Yeah.
Get Doobie back.
Hello.
Welcome back, Doobie.
There's also a capsule downstairs.
I think that's where, like, we have to go back down.
I don't think we push... we have to push that when we're downstairs.
Yeah, we can push this one.
Yeah, yeah.
Push, push, push, push.
Oh god, there's so much.
Chat's all here cheering for us right now.
Oh god, he's right there.
He's right there.
I'm pushing it?
Don't worry!
Be bait!
I'm pushing it!
AHHHHH!
Is anyone dead?
Oh, I just watched Rizmi die.
Yeah, how is Rizmi?
Hello.
We're almost fully... AHHHHH!
I'm back!
Rizmi!
I died, dude.
I can't believe it.
We're all dead.
Oh, yay!
Hello!
Alright, I'll push again.
I guess, Doobie, yours, yeah, you're dead.
Okay.
And then the last one was...
Wait, how- we have to get the last one up top?
I believe in you, Doobie!
Doobie has to push it up all the way here.
Yeah, I know.
That's a lot.
Hopefully she- wait, if she dies, the orb stays down there.
No, no, there's a trade here.
Oh, okay, just get it.
There's a guy behind us.
He's behind us.
Run!
Latex man!
Why did you die?
It's the invisible man from the movie.
Do you hear, like, how squeaky he is?
Yeah, he is.
It's invisible man.
Oh my god, look at Doobie.
Do you see Doobie?
Look at her go into your way up.
He's doing it.
She's doing it.
She's doing it!
I'm behind me!
Oh yeah, that's true.
We have to distract him.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god, I think we're distracting him.
Okay, let's hope Doobie is- is pushing.
Oh, where is he?
Oh, I see him.
I'm gonna go this way.
Okay.
He has to go this way, because Doobie has to push the other way.
Can we do it?
Oh, Doobie, what's going on?
Oh, uh, can you get- go stand on the stairs and then push this thing?
Okay, there.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Alright, where is the latex man?
I think he's distracting him.
Okay.
Alright, we're pushing.
Slow and steady.
I miss.
Push, push.
Push.
Nice.
Yay!
Now what?
Got the dynamite!
Oh, the dynamite!
It was like- Where was that?
Oh my god, where was that?
It was the third- it was like- Outside.
You have to go back through the basement.
Insert the electrical board, open the hatches to the laboratory- Save, save, save, save, save!
Leave the laboratory and blow up the- Oh my god!
I am- Insert the electrical boards open- Ho- what?
Wait.
I'll insert the electrical boards open up- Where's that guy goin'?
We, uh, leave the laboratory?
Oh, never mind.
Hahahaha.
The- the- instructions unclear.
I don't know- Where's the electrical board?
Who makes it on the first floor?
Um- Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Oh!
I was trying to figure this...
We can get more crystals if we lose it.
I'm just looking at the update.
No, we can.
We can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But we can't get more dynamite, apparently.
Oh, in the PC room, you got the electrical board earlier?
Where's PC room?
It looks like bacon.
Guys, at chat, instructions unclear.
Chat, look up the wiki.
Yeah, look up the wiki.
Yeah, let's just leave.
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, virus!
Do me, do me, do me, do me, do me!
We're gonna get blue virus!
Oh, she got blue!
I thought she was in it!
She's hanging out.
Oh, wait, I'm gonna die!
Oh, that's the blue virus!
Aw!
Okay, third floor.
She got moon.
We'll remember her.
Wait, we can revive her at the second floor.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
Isn't there, there's no revive on the third, right?
Mm-mm.
Alright, let's go to the second.
I don't remember.
Too much radiation from the moon.
Alright.
That wouldn't help.
I don't know, I've never been to the moon.
I guess, probably, right?
Too much orange, and all the orange.
Yeah, yeah, and vitamin C.
Alright.
Welcome back.
How was it?
Having the moon virus.
Better than having the COVID virus.
That's so true.
Wait, did we get the...
There was a circuit board from the bottom floor?
What?
Was there?
Did we get the one that was in the lab?
Somebody had one, right?
I don't remember.
Someone was definitely carrying one around.
Oh, yeah, she left.
Oh, she left.
Oh, I know.
It was weird.
Oh, okay.
I was holding it.
Wait, give...
Okay, give us the dynamite.
We'll give you the moon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, Min's gonna get one electrical board.
But she needs...
She needs the vitamin C.
Yeah.
There you go.
Take it.
Wait, oh, wait.
I'll come with...
I'll come with you because, like, you can't hold it with two hands, remember?
Oh, you can't?
I don't know, actually.
I don't think so.
I'm pretty sure you can.
Oh, come on.
Alright, let's go.
We'll have to go anyway.
First floor.
So, where did you die?
I know where I died.
So, where was it?
It wasn't upstairs.
It was downstairs.
Okay, that's good.
That's easier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait.
I'll hold the...
Because then you can grab the thing.
I'll hold the orange.
Okay, then I'll have to hold the fucking electrical board.
Choose one or the other.
It's right here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's a fucking gun.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, you can hold more than two.
Never mind.
See, I told...
You can hold up to three items.
Okay, I didn't know that.
I just thought that...
I thought you can only hold one item.
Cause you...
Oh, I dropped all of them at the same time.
Okay.
Oh, good job.
Yay.
Oh, I see what she meant by the placement.
Yeah, like...
Oh, God.
Now you know.
Yeah.
Alright, we got it.
You're making some people very happy right now.
We got one of the electrical boards.
We don't know what the other ones are though.
Where do we insert it though?
Put it on the back.
Right here.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, so we need...
Three more.
Yeah.
Chat!
Where are the other three?
There's three more.
There's two here.
But I guess somewhere else needs more.
Yeah, there's two.
We didn't see anything, did we?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
The other three are outside?
There's one...
One person.
One singular person.
The one guy.
Alright, do we get one guy?
Oh, somebody said there was one in the computer lab.
Do we trust that guy?
That one guy?
Oh, we have to bring the orange to him too.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Might as well.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cause like...
Where does the dynamite go?
Isn't he gonna turn into like an evil creature though?
No, no.
He seems friendly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's gonna be friendly.
He's gonna join a party.
Yeah, we'll have five people.
What was it?
First floor?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't wanna go back to the basement.
Yeah, this is orange.
It was first floor and then we gotta go to the third floor.
Yeah.
How do we get to the third floor?
We should save.
Oh.
Yeah we should.
Okay.
Okay, I'm just...
Okay, we have to go back to the running man.
Where's the save here anyway?
I don't remember any of this.
This looks good to me.
Oh, wait, put the diamond!
Yeah!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Nice.
Okay, we did that.
Maybe it's a shortcut, yeah.
I bet the electrical boards are out here.
Oh, that's what the one guy said.
Yeah.
Wait, what's this?
Guys, guys, guys.
Oh, that means the third floor is free.
We have to be more careful here, Susan.
Wait.
Um...
So, I opened both doors now.
But, like...
Maybe the electric boards are out here.
Okay, wait, that means the third floor should be, like...
Not dangerous anymore, right?
Yeah, but I don't think we should explore until we save.
Yeah, we should save, yeah.
Where is the save point?
I don't know.
I don't know either.
I saw Slenderman in the other building, so...
Okay, so we should be fine.
And we chained his brother, too.
Famous laughter.
He does like stairs.
Wait, he's gone!
Wait, Doobie said she found it?
Oh!
Doobie, where are you?
Marco!
Go!
Keep talking!
Oh, you're upstairs.
I'm downstairs.
Yeah, yeah, we're downstairs.
We're downstairs.
Oh, yeah, there.
I see.
Where?
Right here.
Oh, nice.
Oh!
Yeah!
Okay, now we can explore.
Okay, now...
Okay, let's go to the TV room, because the monster's not here anymore.
I don't wanna look behind you.
Oh my god.
Okay, there's that guy, though.
Let's go to the TV room.
The third floor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Third floor, third floor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We went up the...
And, like, Mimi and I went up and the monster was gone.
No, I just...
It was, like, here.
Oh, yeah, here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, we did it, guys.
We liberated the third floor.
I don't even know what we're doing, but we're doing it.
Yeah!
We're giving them the orange.
I know, but I just mean in general.
Like...
PTSD in these holidays.
After we found the moon...
Oh, that's how he broke out.
Yeah!
What the heck is that muskash animal?
Where was that?
This school is weird.
I don't...
I don't know, guys.
Is this a school?
Save on the moon.
That's right.
Oh, where is he?
TV man!
Oh, there he is!
Look!
I want an orange for you.
Yeah!
Hey!
Hi!
That guy...
Look at his body.
He's definitely gonna turn into...
Yeah.
I have a TV instead of a head.
But I'm...
Oh, yeah, okay.
This is all the same thing.
Does he want it?
Wait, does he not want it?
Is he just here for storytelling reasons?
Wait, he doesn't want the orange?
Maybe it's the wrong one.
Wrong orange thing.
No!
Okay, then we'll just leave it here.
We don't need it, I think.
Alright, let's save.
We're safe anyway.
Nice.
Alright, so we go outside.
I'm gonna fall from the third story.
Grab a nap.
Alright, let's go.
Here I go!
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Where are we going?
We go outside!
Wait, you guys!
What?
I think there's an electrical panel down here.
Yeah, we have to go outside!
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Remember when...
When we exploded the door?
You think he'll touch us?
With all those baby hands?
I think that one is...
Oh wait!
I can't fall.
I can't walk out the door.
That's like the fence.
You see that fence over there?
That's where we exploded the dynamite.
Yeah, I know, but I thought I would be able to fall.
No, you can't.
You can't do a flip.
I tried jumping off earlier.
Alright, it's this way.
Down we go!
Alright, here we go.
Alright!
Grab that one electrical panel.
Where?
There's something evil here.
There's something evil.
I feel like the entire area is evil.
It needs two of them!
Wait, it needs two?
Yeah.
Oh wait, so this is where the other one is.
Oh, the other two!
Yeah!
Oh, this is the top of the same laboratory.
What's this mustache?
You think that...
I found a shortcut!
Oh, a shortcut!
Oh, nice!
Let's go!
Where is this area?
Wait, that's our safe room!
It's the safe room area!
This is where we met our...
Yeah!
And the kitten!
Okay, we got...
Maybe the electrical board's on the other side.
Remember, there's...
There's that side too.
And we go on the other side.
Anything here?
Wait, there's another area here.
Have we been here?
I don't know.
Everything looks as...
Oh!
Are we good?
I...
Oh, no!
Maybe...
Wait, is that Min on the other side?
Wait, Min's gonna die.
Okay.
Oh, she didn't think she's fine.
I see.
I think she might have got infected.
Wait, is she infected?
Did she...
Wait, we should...
Wait...
Oh, no, she's okay.
She's okay.
Oh, okay.
I like how Nimi...
The...
Nimi's infected body chased after you.
Wait, is there a safe point over here?
You would say she's...
My nightmare.
Alright, let's go...
Uh...
Let's go...
To safe point.
Where's the safe point here?
Are you just sitting?
You can sit here?
Yeah.
I'm just, you know...
Thinking.
Just thinking.
Next to Nimi's dead body.
You know, it's been a long night.
Yeah.
You can take a little breather.
I'm also gonna...
I'm gonna do something to relax.
Take the nerves off.
I hear that.
Clint.
Dance for us.
Yes.
I released the dopamine.
Yeah, I released it.
This is just how I think, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
Let me...
At least it's in stress, you know?
Me too.
Yeah, I feel that.
I gotta do a little flip to...
To feel better.
Alright, where's the...
I just witnessed my friend's death in front of my house.
Where's the safe point for here?
I forgot.
Isn't it by the basement?
Like this way?
Is it?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, the other way, other way.
There's the basement.
Oh, wait!
There's...
No, yeah.
There should be, like, one more.
I...
Can't remember.
Oh, wait!
No, no!
You're right, Doobie!
You're right!
It's the easier one.
Sorry.
Don't listen to me.
Yeah.
Always listen to the yellows.
It was this right here.
Yeah, here.
Found it.
Sorry.
Alright, welcome back.
Welcome back.
Hello.
You like how we danced on top of your dead body?
Yeah.
Maybe.
It was a way to grieve.
Not able to pass into the afterlife.
Wait, guys.
Where are you guys going?
We have to go this way.
Tell me about it.
What can I do for you today?
I'm looking for an electrical panel.
Yeah, we're looking...
Oh, I...
I think it's somewhere, like, on the left side.
I'm thinking, like, over there.
Oh, can you...
Um, and can you recommend me some restaurants nearby?
Yeah, we haven't...
There's no food.
Maybe we're robots.
Just like that robot lady.
Oh, what if we're just...
Oh, what if we're just cyborgs?
Sent to space.
Where...
How are they now?
Wait, where are you guys going?
We have to go out this way.
We do?
Yeah.
Remember when the...
Oh, do you look at the walkthrough?
Yeah.
When they go through the...
The area where Nivi died.
Oh.
Yeah, it was like...
Right here.
Okay, you go first.
You got the flashlight.
Going back.
Uh-oh.
Wait, should we go rest her again?
He spawned camping.
Yeah.
Okay, she's gone.
Let's revive her, I guess.
Oh, wait.
I went the wrong way, sorry.
I didn't even get a chance to react.
He's right...
Guys, he's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh my god, he's here now.
Okay, he's here now, he's here now.
He's here, he's here.
Where?
I saw him.
Yeah, he is here.
He's directly in front of us.
Okay, so we should be able to go now.
We should be able to go now.
What if there's more than one?
I think there's only one.
There could be more than one.
Wait, do we go here?
I think...
He's right there.
Okay, we go here.
Maybe we just go this way.
Guys, let's just go this side.
Okay, we'll just go here.
Oh, I don't know that.
Like that.
Guys, I think we have to go this way.
Guys.
Guys, we just go this way.
I remember this...
We've actually been here already.
We've been to this area already.
That was where the... that was the cafeteria where we opened when we had to go outside the first time.
There's like that second one.
Oh, this is new.
Yeah, this is the new area, right?
And there's evil creatures.
Yeah, I got a steam achievement.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, here.
Where do we go now?
Oh, open the gates to the surrounding area.
We still need to find an electrical board.
Oh, save point!
Save point!
Our girlfriend!
Oh, there she is!
Mommy!
Oh, I found another open gate.
Are you planning to go inside the annex?
What's the annex?
Uh, yes?
No, there are...
Get over here!
Stop talking to your girlfriend!
We have to save!
I'm learning the lore!
We gotta save!
Many of them went there.
But I haven't seen anyone who came back from there.
There's a monster around the corner!
Oh, okay.
I've tried.
She disappeared!
Look how we're all spamming the same game.
Wait, we're going into a new building, that's why.
Oh.
We go in here?
Yeah.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I don't like it.
I hear somebody breathing.
Me too.
I don't see anything on my scanner.
It looks clear.
Maybe he's gone.
Yeah, maybe he just, he got scared away.
From us.
Yeah, we're spooky.
And we're a bunch of baddies.
This looks familiar.
This does look a little familiar.
Everything looks familiar.
Yeah.
Oh.
Wait, there's a, guys!
There's another door here!
There's a, there, it says I need people to be here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, one, two, three...
Wait, we're missing one.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, here, here.
Me.
Oh.
Explore the annex, okay.
Okay.
Is this the annex?
Yeah, but there's a breathing man in here.
Hello!
Hey, that's a friend!
Oh!
Was that her waifu?
Oh, no.
That wasn't.
That's, that's her ex!
The man she tells you not to worry about.
Oh, we just watched our comrade die in front of her.
Oh!
Okay, I got the data on the map.
Hello!
They live?
You think you're alive?
Guys?
Hey!
Did...
Yubi die?
Yeah, I watched her die.
Oh!
I was like how...
It approached Nimi from behind.
Yeah, I know.
Wait!
Hello?
Did you hear that?
Oh!
Nimi!
Nimi, you're alive?!
I'm alive!
I thought I killed you!
I ran.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Oh, so it almost...
Okay.
Go, go, go!
I don't think it can open doors.
Okay, I feel like how none of us closed the door after I said that.
Um, well, you know, it is what it is.
Okay, we should be fine.
We need to find a rest point for Doobie.
Yeah, me too.
But he goes around, though.
One of the capsules is located in the... How big?
Ouch!
How long is this game?
I thought after we open the laboratory, if we, we, like, discover the moon and it'll be over.
I don't hear him.
Should I open up the house?
Okay.
I think we're fine.
I don't know where to go, guys.
I don't know either.
Where's that?
Oh!
I'm alive!
I'm not alive!
Hey!
Where the fuck is the capsule?
Oh my god, we gotta push this capsule so far, DB.
Why do we have to push it so far?
Okay, wait, I can... Oh, it's here, here.
This is a shortcut.
This is shorter.
Amy, right here.
He's coming, he's coming, he's coming.
No, I don't think he can fit it.
He's too thick.
He's too...
We'll be fine.
Oh, he's right, he's right!
He fits, he fits, he fits!
He's all that thick!
Oh!
Oh my god, he's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh my god, he's too thick!
Oh my god,
he's too thick!
Oh my god!
He does, he does, he can open the door, he can open the door!
Oh my god, why is he still there?
How do we get it so fast?
One of us has to be bait.
One of us has to be bait while the other pushes.
Oh my god!
Oh, I just saw me cookie and squash!
Should I?
You're alive!
How did you live?
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm fucking leaving!
I'm fucking leaving!
Oh my god, there has to be a save point somewhere!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, you scared the shit out of me!
Oh my god, I scared the shit out of me!
Oh my god, I'll come back everyone!
I was looking back at the speed!
Look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look back guys!
We're back!
Okay, okay, I...
Oh my god, that guy was sick!
This guy is kind of insane!
Yeah, bro, look at him jumping everywhere!
I know!
You were doing a good job, like, uh...
Dodging him!
I know!
I did!
What if you have that debate?
And we'll put...
Yeah!
Okay, alright!
You're so good at dodging him!
Alright, yes!
Okay, wait, wait, here, here, here, here!
Push here, push here, push here!
It's in here!
Push here, and then you push out from here!
In the front!
Don't worry, guys, I'll distract him!
Don't worry, Doobie and I got this!
I don't think they got...
God, he's behind us!
Who is that?
He's on Nimi!
Oh, okay, let's push it, let's push it!
Let's push it, let's push it!
Oh, I pushed it around!
You're getting in a corner!
I fucked up, I fucked up!
I got scared!
Okay, hold on, hold on!
Okay, okay!
Okay!
Push?
Yeah!
There we go!
It's just...
Wait, Nimi, Nimi!
There's...
Okay, okay, that's good.
We can push it out, right?
Uh, she's no longer distracting him.
So we don't know where he is.
I wonder where Doobie is!
Maybe Doobie's got him!
Oh my god, he's a friend!
He's a friend!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Where is he?
I pushed it!
Guys, I pushed it!
Where is the other capsule?
Where are you guys okay?
What does it mean?
One of the capsule is in the industrial building!
What does that mean?
Are you pushing it?
I did it!
I did one of them!
But one of them is in the industrial building!
Okay, we gotta save!
We gotta go to the save point!
I'm gonna go to the save point!
Safe!
Okay!
Wait, but is Nimi and Doobie alive?
Uh, Nimi was last alive when I saw her.
Oh, okay.
Oh, but...
Maybe she'll know to go if we...
Wait, wait!
Come, come here!
Come here!
Save point!
Come to the save point!
Um...
Right side!
Or you could...
Or you could die!
Or not!
Just...
Just die!
Nimi can be saved!
Okay, we're here.
I'll say...
Mint said wanted you to be dead.
I was like...
Oh!
Just so we could revive easily.
Okay, wait.
Where is the...
Yeah, it says one of those in the industrial building.
Where the fuck is the industrial building?
Yeah, I pushed one of the capsules.
Where to find the other building?
All the way?
Huh?
I don't know.
This looks industrial.
Does this look like...
It does look industrial.
Hello, are you the industrial building?
Oh!
Nice.
Oh, it is industrial.
There's a cat over here though.
One of the kitty cats guys.
Meow, meow.
I hear a breathing man.
Report from squad.
Oh, yeah.
Complete disaster, guys.
Squad, two teams, they've turned into some kind of monsters.
Moving on all fours and they go...
Oh, my god.
They're enormous.
We'll lose everyone.
Guys.
We decided to send one person northwest.
Let them try to find something, anything.
The rest of us are all falling back to the building to search for clues there.
Hopefully this will work.
Over and out.
Don't worry.
We're better than that squad.
Yeah, we're squad.
We're Mickey 17.
Guys, there's three of them.
There's three of them.
Guys, there's four of them.
A cloud with four of them.
Four of them.
How are we gonna push the capsule all the way back?
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
It's not safe.
Poor that guy just walked in.
It's his home.
Yeah.
What is all this noise going on?
Hey, there's a key behind you.
Huh.
I think the lizard guy is friendly.
How did he seize us?
I think he sees us.
I don't know.
Oh shoot.
Wait, okay, I'm gonna be here.
Wait, no, they're all... Oh my god, they're all surrounded.
I think they both died.
Let's revive them.
Um... I don't think so.
I... I don't think they're okay.
I don't think...
Wait, what happened to Min?
Wait, is Min alive?
You've been screaming in the background.
It's okay, I'll be a hero.
One of... I'll wait until...
She'll die eventually, right?
What the fuck is heavy breathing?
Oh!
Oh my god, it's the sentity, man.
Oh, hey!
Welcome back!
Oh wait, we gotta wait for Min to die again.
Oops.
Oh my god.
Um...
All I wanted to do was...
Free the moon.
I thought we were so close.
We're gonna do it.
It's possible.
30 more minutes.
We just... We can do this.
We can save the moon.
Welcome back.
We need the gun.
There's...
We need the...
There's goo...
There's goo all.
Okay, okay.
So then we have to...
We have to...
We can get it in here.
In the building.
Yeah, we can get it in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, someone grab the goo gun.
Oh, I got it.
I got the lab.
Can we enter through here?
I don't think so.
Wait.
If you walk pretty close to them, it seems like they can't jump on you.
So it's a little easier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's in this building.
Okay.
I've yet to see one electrical board, guys.
I don't know.
I don't think we're still...
Maybe the end game, right?
It must be, yeah.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Look at her go.
Ah!
I'm gonna use the bathroom, guys.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
You
did.
Did you shoot the goo?
Yeah, I shot it.
I think we got it.
That's probably what the goo gun was for.
Maybe?
Is there an exit?
Oh, there we go!
Yay!
Push-a-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-push-p I got it.
I'm back.
I was busy watching Mint do her fucking heroic parkour that one of the cats jumped on top of me.
Okay, I remember the deer guy.
Okay.
He's to our right.
Wait, this way's faster.
This way's faster.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
This way.
He's actually kind of over there.
Pusha, pusha, pusha, pusha.
It's okay.
Okay.
In here?
There's on my scanner.
I hear him.
It's here.
Oh, this way?
In here?
Yeah, yeah.
Is he coming?
Okay, one of us conveyed him.
Wait, you keep pushing because I don't know which way.
You push in the left, yeah.
Okay, okay.
No, no, no.
It's on the left.
Okay, that works too, that works too, that works too.
Yeah, yeah.
You're doing me calling him a stupid idiot.
Okay, we did it.
Oh, what'd we get?
I don't know.
Is this an electrical board?
Yes, it is.
Oh my god, we got an electrical board.
Let's go!
Okay, we gotta...
Wait, is this to the thing though?
Here, here, come here, come here.
This way, this way.
This is electrical board, not electrical box.
That's what this is.
Electrical box.
Oh, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
Goodbye.
I went...
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead!
Hello?
No, I have it!
I have the box!
How'd you get it?
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
Can't be everyone here.
I think Doobie's dead.
There.
There you go.
Wait, why don't we put this box in?
Activate the elevator...
Oh, the elevator in the industrial building.
Industrial building.
So this goes in one of the industrial buildings.
Wait, how did you get that?
I don't know.
I dropped it in a dead end.
I have two, maybe?
No, no, no.
It was one.
Wait, so where's the other industrial building?
Oh, oh, oh, yep, yep.
Uh, aren't there three here?
There's four.
Nah, I think there's...
Uh...
Yeah, okay, so we gotta find one of the power supplies and put this on.
Okay.
And one of the industrial buildings.
There's another...
A goo wall.
There's another goo wall in front of us.
Oh, maybe that's where it is.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Let's grab the gun.
Um, where is it?
Oh.
Oh, I got it.
Nice.
Alright.
Wait, where's the...
Where did Nimi go?
See it right there?
Yeah, I got it.
Where's Nimi?
Maybe we're not close enough.
Oh my gosh, I have to be close to it.
Guys, what happened to Nimi, guys?
New item research.
I think she died.
She's finding something.
She found a shovel.
Dig up the items under the...
How many missions?
What?
Oh, oh, oh, whoa.
Oh my god.
Look what you did.
I'm gonna burst him down.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
Doobie's alive.
Doobie is alive.
Doobie?
Oh, you're alive.
Okay, we can bring Nimi.
I think Nimi died.
No, wait.
I think Nimi's alive.
Someone said she has the shovel.
No.
Yeah, but maybe she died with a shovel.
She's alive!
Nimi!
Nimi alive!
We're alive.
I got a shovel.
I was drinking my drink.
Orange trees.
Orange tree.
Orange tree right here.
Dig it, dig it.
There's a guy directly in front of us on the right side in the doorway.
How long is this game?
I don't know.
I think we might have to do a part two.
What is that?
Yellow car?
Where is a yellow car?
Is this yellow?
Why is there... There's like... Ten hundred objectives on our screen.
Oh, Toby!
Get in front of you, Toby!
Toby!
But there's another... Wait, Nimi, there's another trio.
Over here!
Where?
Show me.
Oh, there is!
I see it!
Is it?
Oh, oh, guys.
Do you see the guy in front of us?
Yeah, I see.
Where are yellow cars?
This is a five-hour game?
Holy moly.
Okay, we're at the three-hour mark.
Someone said we're only halfway.
No way.
We're halfway.
Wait, there's a tree.
There's an orange tree.
Orange tree!
Oh, there's another one.
Yeah, I have something to do in like an hour or so.
We just parked.
We just parked!
OOOOOOOHHHH!!
OHH!!
OHH!!!
OHHWH!!!
MEOW MEOW!
MEOW!
GO, Dooby, GO!
Oh, never mind.
Oh.
No, Dooby!
Wait, where did Dooby go?
Dooby is over there.
Dooby found a lever.
This guy is.
Oh, this guy's an asshole.
Yeah.
Doobie's alive.
Yeah, Doobie's alive.
Doobie found a lever is what she said.
Like, I thought when we find the moon, we like, finish the game.
Hi!
Don't worry.
He's not chasing you.
Alright, nice.
No, he was.
Alright, we gotta get the shovel back.
We gotta get the shovel back.
Shovel.
Shovel time!
Uh, why these guys are aggressive?
Alright, alright, alright.
Whoa!
Come on, Dougie!
You got caught by the worm!
We might have to get the shovel back to the venue.
Oh, I thought he was safe!
I thought he was safe!
I thought he was friendly!
Yeah!
I didn't realize!
I thought he was friendly!
Should I get it, Dougie?
Yeah, let's rest, Dougie.
Hey, come back!
Guys, I thought he was friendly!
Why would you think anything in this game is friendly?
I don't know!
I just said hi to him!
I'm gonna go be a hero!
Oh, you're gonna get their shovel?
No, I'm gonna
try...
I know!
I-I unlocked the door there.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna grab this... Yeah, you can go straight.
There you go.
I'm gonna dig this area.
Wait, did we do this tree already?
Wait, I got the shovel.
Oh, you did?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
What did Nimi do?
She's gonna go... try and activate the... the... elevator.
Oh!
Yeah, the elevator.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, as soon as we see it, activate it, we know she did it.
Oh... oh!
Oh!
I think they're looking at us?
Nah.
I hear them.
There's a second goo door?
What?
Ah!
There's a save over there!
There's a save right there!
Oh!
Save!
Come here!
Mid-Mid, come here!
Oh!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, can't go in the elevator, can't go in the elevator.
We just leave?
Where did Mint go?
Mint, come over here, Mint, come over here.
Hold on, I'm getting the gun.
Don't, she's getting it.
America.
I have the gun already.
She has the gun.
Mint, she has the gun.
Mint.
Yeah, we have it!
Get over here!
Get your ass over here!
Okay, we got Rizzer.
I can't think we got Rizzer.
Oh, wait!
We have to wait, because she... Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Okay, now we can... Oh, okay, now we can do it.
Oh my god, three seconds.
Okay, alright, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Everybody, my chat lied to me.
What did they say?
They said that you needed a gun.
Yeah, she has a gun.
Yeah, I didn't know that.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, Doobie, I think you're muted again.
Oh, hello.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, we can hear you, we can hear you.
Yeah, we can hear you.
There's a bridge!
Hey, there's a bridge here.
There's so much panting everywhere.
I know, all the meow-meows.
That's what you call them?
Yeah, they're the meow-meow.
The meow-meow.
We're getting to the second floor of Edenx.
Oh, nice!
Uh-oh.
A little body!
Yay!
Oh.
It's fine, we're fine, we're fine.
We're fine!
Oh, whoa!
Close this.
Same point!
Safe point, same point, same point.
Oh my God, we're okay!
Okay, we're okay.
No.
Aw.
No, we're not okay!
We're not okay!
Oh no, it's so weird.
It's so weird.
Are they alive?
I don't know.
I don't know if they're dead or not.
I can't tell.
Oh wait, they're alive, they're alive.
We need a fresh corpse.
Wait, wait, is... Is Mint alive?
No, she died.
Oh, let's get her back, let's get her back.
We can get her back, yeah.
All right, we'll come back.
I got got by an eyeball, so be careful.
Wait, what about the... Wait, the electrical box is here?
We're supposed to place a fresh astronaut corpse here.
Well, we can do that.
What if I could get the... It could've been me.
Oh, do we have to die to it?
No, I don't think so.
I think we have to find one.
Yeah, I think we got... Eyeball, eyeball, eyeball.
I got double-teamed.
Oh, Nimi!
There's only... There's only Nimi left!
There's a lot of pushing puzzles involved.
I got double-teamed.
Oh, now it's all up to her.
Go, Nimi, go!
Oh!
That was so close.
Oh my god.
I don't even know where she is.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Where is she?
Guys, I don't even know where she is!
I'm lost for it.
Have we always had... How do you even use the map?
Okay.
Tool, action, menu, tug... There's no map option... Oh!
Oh!
Oh, she did it!
She put a shortcut!
Nimi, please!
Save!
Oh, save!
Oh, my God, I'm confused!
Yay!
You were gaming!
You were gaming so hard!
Guys, guys, guys, guys, watch out.
Be careful.
Okay.
Okay, so we gotta figure out the capsule.
I think the capsule comes from us.
Oh, shot?
No.
I can't... Oh, my God, I can't... I can't do anything!
I can't... I can't... Thank you!
Oh, I think Juice... Oh!
Okay.
Oh, disappeared.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, welcome back.
The other guy was a pain in the ass.
Not gonna lie.
The guy with the sword?
Yeah.
Here he comes.
Why is it always me?
Why?
Wow.
Is that the trick?
Yeah, that's the trick.
Oh, you... Oh, you... Emote!
Oh, my God.
That's a good one.
Oh
Oh my god, this is so much stuff.
Wait, it's just the same capsule I found before.
Okay.
Well, first we need to find a fresh corpse.
I don't think Doofy does.
I don't think she does.
There's two capsules?
Oh my god, Doofy's famous last words.
Guys, I think it's the corpse that's like shown in the little hole.
Yeah, downstairs?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, so we go downstairs?
There's also other stairs.
Okay.
This guy sucks, the sword locked.
No, it's not.
It's not locked.
Wait, is he right here?
That's an old one.
Yeah, we're here.
There it is.
Watch that guy die, remember?
So he's fresh.
Yeah!
Oh!
I mean, it was like an apple.
Oh my god.
He's fresh!
Wee!
Yes!
Fresh meat!
Okay, we...
Woo!
Helicopter!
Wait, I'm turning around.
Where are we?
It's just a little bit.
Where's that, right there?
Oh!
Oh, we just made one.
We made a new worm.
Oh, there we go.
Oh!
Please!
Okay.
Let's get a second.
Your sacrifice is not in there.
Oh my god!
Oh, it's coming for me, isn't it?
It goes through doors?
Oh my god!
Are you alive?
Oh,
mint it spawned!
Get out!
I have to go back and save them!
Oh no, oh no, oh no!
No, I'm not dead!
Oh my god, he's on me.
Oh my god.
Are you dead?!
Oh, I don't know if she's dead or not.
I don't know, I said I've let her die so I can impress!
No, no, no, no.
Are you alive?!
Oh my gosh, she better be fucking dead.
Oh my god!
Let's go, let's go!
Push, push, push, push, push, push!
Push, push, push!
Only Doobie knows where it is!
Okay, go, go, go!
Okay, I'll leave the way.
This way, this way!
Okay.
It's in a corner!
Okay, we do this!
There you go!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
He's upstairs!
He's by the same point!
Oh, he is!
I'm pushing, I'm pushing!
He's walking over to the left!
I'm pushing!
Oh my god, I'm pushing so fast!
Hold on, I gotta check where we're going on.
She's behind!
He's behind us!
No!
It's up there!
He's behind you!
Oh, no!
Oh!
He ran into the same point!
One of them is in the same point!
It's okay.
Oh, no!
They're both velocity cameras!
I'm almost there!
I got... I can't try.
Oh, no!
You're almost there!
Well, I'll distract the guy, I guess.
Oh, no!
She doesn't know!
We're all dead!
Okay.
We'll find the moon one day.
Oh, Doobie's so smart!
Your eyeball!
Oh, no!
Bad time!
That was such a bad time!
I was such...
Okay, I...
I was like, Oh, Doobie's so smart!
And then you got ran over by the eye!
Oh!
Pies!
I'll distract him!
Yeah, yeah!
Why was distract him?
Well, we'll distract him!
I did it!
I distracted!
I...
Wait!
You died, too!
Oh, no!
Wait, cause the eyeballs have passed!
Oh my god, it's...
It's Doobie again!
I believe!
Oh, this is where the other...
Oh!
This air is so hard!
What the fuck?
Okay, he's still downstairs!
I feel like there's gotta be a way to tease it!
Yeah, there has to be!
Oh, he's still downstairs?
He has to be, because I let him downstairs when we save.
Maybe, like, one of us just has to bring him downstairs, and then, like, run around.
Yeah.
But then how will we know when the other person's, like, dead?
Like, when it's just us left?
Wait, is he there?
Alright.
Where is he?
He was by the save point!
Okay.
Wait, we're by the save point.
We'll try and lure him.
We're by the save point.
Oh.
Put him downstairs!
Oh, he's downstairs?
No, we're gonna bring him downstairs.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Open the door.
We're going to bring the man downstairs!
The scary man!
Yeah, you guys push the thing and watch for the eyeball.
Go, go, go.
Is he coming over?
I hear him.
Yeah, me too.
Alright.
We got this.
We can literally loop around this.
No, we can loop around this.
This garbage can.
I can loop in here.
Oh, he's coming for you, Doobie!
Oh, I'll stay here.
Just in case he fucks up.
Just in case Doobie dies and comes back.
I think that'll be fine, right?
It's dead by daylight time.
We're dbd-ing.
Doobie, are you alive?
Team Yellow, we're brave.
We're brave people.
I don't know if Doobie's alive.
I think Doobie I think I think Doobie died.
I think Doobie died.
I actually think she died.
She's dead.
She has to be dead.
Oh my God, please don't jump.
Please don't jump.
I Oh my god, they better be doing this.
Oh my god, they did it.
They did it.
Did you guys do it?
I guess that's why.
Oh, I did it.
Okay, I looped him.
Okay, he's still downstairs.
Wait, but there's only... there's two more that we need.
Well, where's the other two?
I saw one.
He's not downstairs.
Wait, he's not downstairs anymore?
No, he just chased after us.
Oh, there he is.
Where are the other two capsules?
Oh, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Oh my god.
Okay, what's over here?
Any more capsules?
Maybe there's a... Oh, it's this area!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the third floor!
Maybe there's more capsules downstairs.
Wait, are they alive?
We can try.
Oh.
Alright, do you guys know where the...
There's one on this floor.
There's a door that was unopened.
Okay, so I'll try and lead the other...
Okay, we'll try and lead them back downstairs again.
Because I know how to lead them.
Do we see them?
I'll lead them back down.
Wait, there is a... There's a capsule downstairs.
Wait.
I see a capsule downstairs.
You see one downstairs?
Yeah, on the...
Okay, I'll lead them.
Oh my god.
I can't loop because I'm being chased by Nimi.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He's taking...
I was like, I said...
I was gonna be taking charge.
What the fuck?
He charged right at me.
He jumped up here.
Fuck.
It's okay.
We saved.
Where am I?
Oh no.
It's all up to Doobie again.
They've been turned into some kind of giant worm.
It's now crawling across the floor.
It's a nightmare.
Get us out of here before it's too late.
If this keeps up, we'll be the next turn to work.
The moon isn't here.
Not even close.
Are you seeing Katy Perry right now?
I'm just paying for anything to stop.
It's more, I guess.
This is the spawn room.
Oh.
Fireworks.
It was apes.
Maybe we should save this for part two.
Yeah.
We'll be back.
They've just...
Yes.
This is like 3-0.
We've... we've resulted the scene.
We keep dying, we keep coming back.
We've cloned ourselves so many times.
I know.
We're Mickey 500 at this point.
Yeah, we're Mickey 500.
Oh, Divi, you're muted, I think.
Oh, hello, sorry.
Hello.
I'm down to do a part two of this.
Because we were halfway, apparently.
We were halfway.
I want to release the moon.
We got it.
Yeah, we got to save the moon.
We got to save the moon.
Thank you for joining me in this collab, guys.
Thank you for playing.
Thank you.
Yeah.
We'll get him next time.
Wait, what was the breakdancing one again?
Oh, I got it.
That's three.
Yeah.
It's three.
I hear these sound effects in my dreams.
Boom.
Oh my God.
I'm so done with the slam dunk.
Thank you guys for watching.
Yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you everyone for joining us.
I had a great time with green and yellow today.
Team yellow vs.
team green.
That was great.
Alright, we'll figure out when to play part 2 later.
Sometime, yeah.
Yeah, thank you guys.
Thank you guys.
Thank you!
Alright, I'll see you guys later.
I'm gonna go talk to my chat.
Yeah, me too.
Alright, I'll see you guys.
Bye-bye!
I'll save it.
I think it's saved.
It should be saved when I'm saved.
He's like, I don't even know what... Yeah, I'll save it.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll save it for us.
Thank you for watching!
Wait, wait, wait!
Get over here!
I need to save this.
Yeah, don't worry.
Nimi's just gonna breakdance.
I hope the host can... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure it saves because, like, last time when we remade the lobby, it saved.
Oh!
Gosh, these sound effects.
I swear to God, that guy fucking slams up you.
Alright, I'll see you guys!
Bye-bye!
Woo!
Alright, let me swap real quick.
Oh my gosh, it's been a while since... since we went to a chatting screen together, guys.
Woah!
It's been a while since we're here at the saloon.
But thank you guys!
Wow!
That was really fun!
I had a great time with, uh...
Nimi, Doobie, and Min.
That was a really fun collab.
I always get really nervous in these types of collabs because it's like, you know...
Um...
Uh...
It's, you know...
I know a lot of people were looking forward to this.
Um...
Like, this has been a collab that a lot of people wanted to happen for a very long time.
So, I'm very happy that we were able to...
Um...
I was able to organize it for all of us and, um...
Have our schedules finally fully aligned and everything.
Uh, yeah.
Um...
So, yeah, and...
I was, you know, always the thing he's worrying about is like...
Will the game be fun for us?
Uh...
I hope, like, the game be fun for us.
And also, like...
Um...
And also, the fact that we...
I wanted it, uh...
Um...
Like, all of us to have fun together.
Yeah.
And Nimi and Doobie and Min were all super fun together.
And we...
There was just lots of moments.
I hope the volume was okay.
Um...
That was what...
I was worried about the volume, too.
So, I hope it was okay, guys.
Um...
Cause I know, like...
We couldn't really...
Really, you know, balance it quite well.
In terms of, like...
Cause everything was connected to one fucking setting.
For some reason.
So...
I hope you guys could hear everybody okay.
Cause that was like, you know...
Um...
Yeah, the proximity chat.
Yeah.
Nimi was a little quiet.
I think, like, in the beginning...
Every...
Like, she was, like...
Loud.
I think, like...
I think she was, like, just far...
Further away from her mic...
Later on.
Yeah.
Uh...
So I'm glad you guys could cure them fine.
Yeah, that's...
Yeah.
There were so many...
I swear to god.
I got the timing...
Uh...
I got timed.
Every time.
The time.
Then...
I get time.
The timing.
I...
I was like...
Uh...
And I was like, aw, Doobie is so smart.
And then she fucking dies.
I'm just like, I'm sorry, Doobie.
I cursed her.
I cursed her and she had to die for my sins.
But yes, I finally do donation reading time again.
I can finally do it again after my busy hell month.
Chikori, thank you for the gifted chip.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, my jinx.
I'm a hero!
And then we're like, Crouch, Devi, Crouch!
And it's like, Devi!
Devi, Crouch!
It was so unfortunate.
Oh my god, she could have made it.
But yeah, we'll definitely try and do a part two.
We'll try to do a part two and we'll try and...
Please never say I'm safe, judging by the stream I would get instantly hit by the truck.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're halfway.
We're halfway through this, so...
We'll try to organize a part two.
So we can finally save the moon.
Like...
Like, were we supposed to...
Is the electrical board...
Like...
Like, part of the...
Like, I'm like, where the fuck are the electrical boards?
I'm so confused.
Do we have to, like, do that building area to get the electrical board, guys?
Because I'm like...
Like, we got the moon.
And then suddenly we're, like, doing something else.
I lost...
Yeah, that's where I lost the plot of the game.
Suddenly we're, like, in a new area.
Like...
I'm so confused.
And then, like, map data gathered.
And I was like, map data?
I was like, how...
How...
Where did I open the map?
Um...
Forward.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the stream.
You guys triggered a coffin fit out of me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm super happy.
I was able to finally organize it with all of us.
And...
Um...
But that was...
That was really fun.
I had a great time.
I, like, laughed a lot.
Yeah, I felt like, like, we got to the moon.
And then, we, like, went backwards.
In progress.
I don't know what happened.
Like...
I felt like...
Like, I felt like we went backwards.
It's just, like, we stopped progressing after we found the moon.
Um...
Sage, thank you for the super chat.
Like, after we died to the fucking...
To the...
The sword man, like, seven times in a row.
I was like, guys, I think...
Let's just...
Let's just stop here.
I...
Oh, Doobie!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Thank you so much to the raid!
Um...
I had a great time, Doobie.
I hope...
Welcome!
Welcome, Dooberts!
Um...
Welcome, little D's.
Uh...
I am just doing super chat reunion right now.
I'm just chilling, really.
Hahaha!
But...
Welcome, welcome to the saloon!
Um...
I'm just reading my super chats at the moment.
Uh...
Captain Bob!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Welcome, little minions!
Yes!
Hahaha!
During the moon adventure!
The little...
Haha!
The little D's are here!
Um...
Uh...
Thurmon!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Nah, nah, nah...
Oh my gosh!
I wanna play Moonbase Alpha so badly!
Um...
That's, like, one of the games that I've been wanting to play for the longest time.
What if we just do space games?
Like...
Hahaha!
What if...
Cause, like, Moonbase Alpha is only fun when there is, like...
Like, a lot of us.
Oh my...
But I don't even know the plot!
I don't even know, like, what the plot...
Was for...
Haha!
Like, what the...
The game plot is for Moonbase Alpha.
Cause, it's like...
All I know is just, like, the text to...
Speech.
Oh!
Hahaha!
John Madden!
The voice mo...
Yeah, the voice...
The voices is the plot.
Yeah!
Hahaha!
It has...
It's the face...
It's the face on the moon!
Doki!
Of course that's the plot!
Um...
El, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
El, Doki!
Don't get the others banned just like you did with Chibi and Doki!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Professor!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh, yes!
Next week...
Um...
Next week, our collab is gonna be with the Sloppy Sisters.
So, we're gonna be playing Peak next week.
I don't know if Laimo or Snuffy has played Peak yet, but Min and I have yet to play Peak.
I made sure to, like, not play the game yet until my first collab.
Um...
So, that's gonna be next Friday.
Uh...
But I don't know...
I know Min hasn't, but I don't know if Snuffy or Laimo has yet.
So, we're just gonna go with zero...
Uh...
In advance.
And also, with the Sloppy Sisters, we plan that in advance as well.
Um...
And...
I try to make sure to, like, not spoil myself until that collab.
Um...
So, yeah.
Cause I had, like, invitations from other VTubers to join, but I said, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
I wanna go in blind first.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
And then I can join later!
Ha ha ha ha!
Uh...
Seijin!
Thank you for the multiple super stickers!
Thank you!
Uh...
Vyrysan!
Thank you, thank you!
Toki out here in BMI!
Um...
AK!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for such a silly collab...
I don't think Nimi's ever had so many Ebombs dropped on our stream!
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Also, I don't know what our name- our group name is!
I don't know.
I don't know what...
Uh...
With Nimi, Mint and Adobe- was it Team Yellow Green?
Ha ha ha!
I don't know!
We haven't really- really...
Um...
No, like, figure out what our group name should be.
Green and yellow.
Oh, but that's the space sister.
Wife swap.
We'll figure it out.
Maybe in part two, we'll figure out what our name will be.
Luca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Crank that soldier boy.
Matt, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Grab that lever, Kronk.
Uh, Icy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Doki, it's my birthday today.
I had a great time watching your birthday concert at AX.
Did you get a free slushie at 7-0?
Oh, is it today's 7-0?
Ah!
No, I didn't.
I didn't get my free slushie.
Thank you for the super chat, Icy.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Icy.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Oh my gosh, I forgot to show you guys.
Just remembered.
Guys, you guys didn't know my birthday merch dropped.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, I... I was like, what's my image for this?
And it was live action Jumba and Plinkly.
Okay, let me replace that real quick.
Guys, let me... Whoa, that angie.
Let me see.
Where's my birthday merch?
Oh my gosh, where is it?
Where did I save the birthday merch from now?
Where is it?
They're not saving?
Oh wait, I saved it in my birthday folder.
Is it here?
Oh, here you go.
Yeah!
Okay, so... Oh my gosh, it's a giant image.
Pinned in my chat right now.
It's Doki Merch.
It's basically DokiMerch.com.
And you can get my... There's a lot of items there, but there's... You can buy my birthday bundle right now or any of the birthday merch individually.
But yes.
You can, you know, support me and build your shrine.
Um... I love... I'm so happy that the merch store is out now.
Um... And we have so many items... Uh... In works there.
And plan... Um... Planned... Um... In the future.
So yeah!
Buy my merch.
Ha ha ha ha.
Um... Seijian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He is friendly.
Uh... Actual, thank you for the magenta soup.
But thank you, thank you.
Don't disrespect the little...
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Uh... Fuda.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, you're killing me with laughter watching this stream.
Everyone is hilarious.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think it's because, like, we all also are, like, very experienced streamers.
And, you know, we all have, like, our own, like, strengths.
and amazing community in our own right.
So, like, we combine all our powers together.
Uh...
We combine all our powers together to... as a group.
Uh... Um...
Because I like... I think, like, um...
The more experience you have, the more easier it is to do, like, back and forth with people.
Um... and other VTubers.
Because, like, you know...
Like, it's all about building your improv skills.
Um... Alan, Neppers, Manya, War, and JL.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh... Luca, thank you for the super chat.
I don't... I think we're safe, the narrator.
They were, in fact, not safe.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Seijian, thank you again for another super sticker.
Um...
Uh... Ayoko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, I think Doobie's curse of dying a lot has been passed down to you now!
No, Doobie... Doobie got like... She had such bad luck.
Oh my god.
She would either be the last person to live or the first person to die.
It's one or the other.
And then I, at the beginning, I was the last person to live.
And then later on, like, I just kept dying first.
Like, every time... All the monsters were just fucking aggro to me.
I don't know why.
I...
It is like... For some reason... Everyone just was like, fuck her in particular.
Like, I get friends.
And then the guy... And then two of my teammates... Mint and Nimi... Were emoting in front of him.
I was by the door.
And then the guy kills me first.
Like, I was like... What?
I was like... What?
You guys were closer.
Like...
I was like... And then I fucking just see... Like... Nimi and Mint just fucking dancing... In front of him.
Strike.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't keep by daylight looping, though.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad... Oh yeah.
But dad's working because he wants to walk you soon.
But I'll walk him after... After the super chat reading.
I only have a few super chats left.
Um... Uh...
R.C.T.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O.O Hello.
Thank you for the super chat, seguicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicicic Uh,
cry, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Phantom, Bird, Nightmare, Jaboa, PB&J.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Uh, Maddie, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Green and yellow women, or gay women for short.
Quoted from...
No, no, no, no.
I'm almost done, I'm almost done.
What?
I don't know why, but he stopped barking when I, like, scold him like an Asian mom.
He's like, every time, every time I scold him like an Asian mom, he just, like, walks away.
It works.
It works every time.
L, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Green and yellow woman.
It's okay, woman.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I like green and yellow woman.
Strike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mintcord is pushing for green and yellow, aka gay.
Okay.
Luca, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
What the fuck?
Dad is bilingual?
Even the dog is smarter than you because he's bilingual.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Your dog speaks Chinese?
It's because he grew up with me and my parents.
My parents would speak Chinese to him.
And then I'd speak Chinese.
And then like... and he knows he's been our bad boy when I pulled out the Cantonese.
Yeah.
Chikori, did you give us a super chat?
Thank you.
If English doesn't work, do it again with Cantonese.
English just isn't threatening enough, guys.
The English language is not threatening enough, guys.
When an Asian... okay, you know you're in big trouble when they pull out the Cantonese or Chinese.
Because Cantonese, you can say something like really mundane, but it sounds like... it sounds like I'm yelling at you.
Like, I can make it sound like I'm yelling at you in Cantonese because we can make it sound super harsh even though it's like something like, you know, super mundane.
Yeah, it's the tone.
Yeah.
Example, I'll be like...
Uh...
Let's see.
I'm trying to think of something I can say.
That sounded like... really mean.
But, uh... what I said was...
Hey, did you know today you did really good?
Yeah!
And I literally said... did you know today?
I was like, hey, today you did really good.
But I said, like, it just sounded super harsh.
Yeah.
What did you say to me?
Oh...
Yeah, it sounded like I scolded you, but I told... like, in Cantonese, you can make it sound, like, super harsh.
Um...
Yeah, it's an aggressive compliment.
I'm sorry!
Um...
Let's see.
Hey, guys, thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I read that already.
Smug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Professor, thank you for the super chat.
Okay, I think those were all the super chats for today.
But I had a great time, everyone.
Oh, I'll give you guys a dad update.
Uh...
I...
But today...
Okay, what is it today?
Oh my god, dad's been...
Been a very bad boy lately.
I don't know why.
He's been, like, super aggressive towards other dogs lately.
So, like, I've been, like, bringing treats down just to, like, try to make him, like, more calm.
But, like, the last two days, for some reason, he's, like, really, really aggressive for some reason.
So, I've been, like, carrying him to the dog park because I didn't want him to, like, try and trigger anything.
Right, saying with Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
So, I hope it's just a phase for him.
I don't know.
Maybe he's, like, extra moody or something.
Captain, he's golden voice pack for us.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, maybe in the future.
Maybe.
But, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki, I've also been a bad dragoon!
Can you call me a moron and can't send me?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll think about it.
Okay, um, but...
Oh, okay, wait, I wrote this down.
Um, okay, so, like, yesterday, um...
He had an incident yesterday.
um, he tried, for some reason, cause like, usually he'll ignore the dogs.
And just like, um... um, play with me.
Um, cause I'd bring his ball down.
But really yesterday, he like, he...
there- there were a lot, I think he got like, overloaded, with like...
Cause there were so many dogs at the dog park yesterday- yesterday night.
And I think he got like super overloaded.
Because um, there're too many dogs at the dog park And they were all, like, running around.
And he feels, like, threatened.
And then, so, like, I was playing fetch with Dad.
And then there was a bunch of dogs near him were, like, running around.
And he didn't like that.
And he got, like, super over-simulated.
And, like, he, like, ran up to, like, one of the big dogs... the big dog there?
Because the big dog was, like, playing with, like, some small dog... like, medium and small dogs.
And was, like, um, like, you know, running around.
And he doesn't like it when dogs run around too much near him.
So he, like, ran up to the big dog, I guess, to establish dominance and started, like, barking at them.
Because usually, like, his experience at the dog part, when he barks at them, they, like, back off.
But this time, like, this big dog was, like, not having it.
He was like, oh, you're gonna bark at me?
I'm gonna teach you a lesson.
And then, like, he started, like, barking back at dad.
And he was like, he was like, and he, like, started chasing dad.
Like, he was, like, you know, almost wanting to nip him.
And then dad freaked out because he didn't think he was gonna get challenged.
Because, like, he hasn't been challenged like that.
And he was, like, he was yelping and, like, ran into my arms.
And was like, pick me up, mom, I'm gonna go home.
Yeah, he fucked around and found out.
Yeah.
He was like, we can bark back?
So, at the moment that the big dog started chasing him, like, dad was, like, I, like, because, like, I knew he was trying to fight.
Like, I knew he was trying to get in a fight.
So, I instantly got up and, like, went up to him.
But, like, but then, obviously, that's too late.
And then, like, dad, like, quickly, like, you know, his tail underneath.
And, like, ran over to my arms because I bent down.
And he ran over to my arms.
And he was like, pick me up, pick me up.
And then, like, he was like, I want to go home.
Play stupid games, win stupid prizes.
It's like, they can do that, they can bark off back.
That's illegal.
I know, right?
Like, none of the other big dogs ever punished him.
But this is like the first time a big dog was like, bro, you picked the wrong fight today.
Um, uh, Noriko.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I second that Doki Kanto's scolding voice pack.
This is my advanced deposit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, uh, Slime.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I won't pay for such a pack.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Toki.
Every time you speak Cantonese to dad, it's very familiar.
It's like parents I see on the street in Hong Kong.
Luca, he should have barked in Cantonese.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here now.
Thank you all for coming.
I had a great time today on stream.
I had a great time with Mimi, Doobie, and Mint.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get them around, get that blood flowing.
And if you, stay up for me, head to bed, cuz you deserve it.
Tomorrow, we're gonna try and finish Halo.
I'm definitely gonna try and finish Halo tomorrow.
I'm gonna do a long intern stream until Halo is done.
So that's tomorrow's plan.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I used to have a German Shepherd once.
When walking, a loose poodle came barking.
My dog grabbed him, swung him around, and threw him.
The poodle never came back.
The little dude didn't understand size.
Holy shit.
Yeah, that's why I'm scared of what happened with Dad.
I'm not scared that that would happen to him.
And then you have the super chat.
Thank you.
Holy fuck, that's crazy.
Yeah, you know, he needed to be taught a lesson, though.
Like poodles, poodles have it too good for too long.
Anyway, guys, I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye!